all right people we are live on the
YouTube and we're kicking off 2018 with
the editor-in-chief of The Daily wire
and a man whose facts don't care about
your feelings Ben Shapiro
welcome back that's not news work I am
doing well we just did a major download
on Star Wars for the past half-hour we
did we should have been streaming a hit
of it say I'm not trying to talk Star
Wars than anything else we're getting
talked about yeah we're gonna talk about
Empire's building and crumbling and
ilium poll and good and light and dark I
don't know how much is gonna be related
to the force but yeah I don't know
either
and how much is gonna be related to that
horrible subplot on Kent you know like
whatever it is the gambling planet that
was the gambling planet that was he's
doing okay first of all when they free
let's do it when they free the kangaroo
camel okay and then she finally says now
it's worth it yeah like you should you
should die in a fiery ball of hate that
was just that entire subplot just
garbage all they to do was change two
things in the movie works they have to
make kylo call off the attack on the
transports and raise sides with him and
then we don't know what's going on we
don't know if there's a light side and a
dark side we don't know if it's all if
they've finally critted the unified
force or what the deal is and Luke and
Leia are still alive out there going
what is going on there have been so
interesting they do that and also they
just get rid of that entire horrifying
subplot that never should have happened
and all could have been done away with
by Laura Dern just saying to Poe first
of all I know weather learns there but
they've been by Laura Dern saying to Poe
by the way we're going to fly to that
planet right there that we're looking at
that one yeah right as opposed to well
now have a 35-minute waste of my time
yeah the Lightspeed thing was pretty
cool but that should have been at bar
you know fingers wrap yeah then should
have died in both movies not even about
snow so here's my Lightspeed thing okay
yeah if that is a weapon if Lightspeed
is a weapon yeah then why wouldn't they
have used it in the first Star Wars film
right well they're so for right they get
in and it's this whole thing about how
they have to shoot the proton the the
photon torpedo down there down the hole
instead it why doesn't when they just
like go to that place and then shoot
through the through the Death Star why
do you ever get tired of being so
factual Shapiro
does it ever get exhausting for you yeah
I mean that's why you talk about Star
Wars but it
all right we got a lot to do here I do
have a few of these I don't know that
I'm gonna get any on that first off I
want you to know in the years that we've
been doing the Reuben report I've never
had to spend money on security but it
cost me six hundred thousand dollars to
secure my home and this studio my garage
just for you to be here that's how can I
help it's worth it I mean see I've sized
the cost I have the Mossad on the roof
the whole thing incredible yeah well
thank you for that I appreciate it I
feel very secure did you ever think if
if I would have talked to Ben Shapiro
five years ago before I knew you and
before so much change in these last
couple years that talking about the
things that you talked about that to me
are whether I agree or disagree and
we're gonna get into both of those but
that are basically mainstream
conservative views did you ever think
you would be thought of as so
controversial I can safely say that the
last five years have been one giant what
the WTF because yeah I mean the idea
that they would require over half a
million dollars of security and hundreds
of police officers for me to go and say
that identity politics is stupid at
Berkeley yeah like I literally said that
the year before with no security right
so it's it's all bizarre and it just
shows you that everyone has lost their
minds I think that work through the
looking-glass at this point do you see a
moment when it happened because I think
there's a couple points we can all look
to that it started to happen and I think
a little bit of our old former friend or
whatever you want to call him Milo add a
lot to do it didn't Trump and just the
trolling and it reaching out into the
world and all about I actually think
that if I were gonna peg a moment when I
think that it really when America may
have jumped the shark when when things
started to go awry in a serious way I
probably would look to Ferguson what
happened in Ferguson because they having
the president of the United States
basically say that riots are justified
if you like what the rioters are
standing for even if the facts don't
even support the story that the rioters
are standing for I think that drove
people out of their minds and on both
sides I think that it made people feel
like the narrative was more important
than facts on one side and if the
narrative is more important than facts
on your side then it must be more
important on my side too so we'll just
hunker down in our respective identity
politics bunkers and it's a night but
each other yeah and get very angry over
over without any common basis of facts
because I mean this is why I focus so
much on facts and listen I'm not gonna
pretend that every opinion I have is if
but when there's a fact I try to
distinguish it from my opinion I'll try
to give you the fact and then say and
now here's my opinion on the fact once
we got away from the common basis of
fact it's very difficult to have a
conversation at all and that's why I
think people are always surprised when I
speak on campus and then when I speak
with people who I disagree with on
politics all the time and we can have a
nice cordial conversation so long as we
agree what's a fact and what's a what's
an opinion yeah but that's getting
harder right I mean just getting people
to agree on the set of facts is becoming
virtually impossible people are offended
so much by the fact that they feel like
a fact is is offensive to who I am as a
human being and this is the one that
I've run into the most obviously this is
whenever I say if I say that I think
that you know poverty is largely caused
by human behavior as opposed to by
identity then people take that as though
I'm casting aspersions against their
identity if I go on campus and I say
that according the Brookings Institute
right just get married before you have
babies hold a job graduate high school
and you won't be permanently poor in the
United States people get offended cuz
they say well but I'm poor and I didn't
fulfill maybe one of those rules but I'm
still the person so why would you say
something like that so it's it's much
easier I think to be offended than to
take responsibility for your own actions
and that has unfortunately I think
fallen on all sides to where do you
think the Conservatives then dropped the
ball on this like the fact that so many
people are turning to you right now and
I think I messaged you my husband was at
Home Depot and there was a guy working
there who was you know a stock guy
Mexican stock guy and he was blasting
ben shapiro show on his and every like
you know Blasi no head yeah yeah just
blasting it and it's like I'm two aisles
over and I'm like is Shapiro over there
but that what if something happened
obviously to conservatives that they got
completely tuned out and then you sort
of have led this I think resurgence of
this I mean I think the point is there a
fourth guy on that I mean in terms of
fault I think that conservatives have
never spoken well in terms of morality
in terms with with it out of politics
they've always spoken in terms of
statistics and data and they do the Paul
Ryan accountant routine and so when
people think of conservatives they think
of one or two things they think of Paul
Ryan with an accounting briefcase or
they think of Pat Buchanan or maybe
Donald Trump saying something that they
find offensive and those are the ways
that people
identify with conservatism or identify
what conservatives are and what I've
tried to do is say that there is a moral
tenor to the facts here's my moral
narrative but here are the facts that
I'm drawing them from and I'm less
concerned about how you feel about that
than I am about whether it's true or not
and that seems to be in an era where
people's feelings are so high somebody
just coming out and saying listen your
feelings don't matter to me like at all
yeah and here's what I think is true and
if you like it if you don't you know and
I'm not coming out to try and hurt you
or anything I'm just saying what I think
is true if you're offended tough badugi
is like and you know that's that seems
to have found a place for some people so
I was actually going to do this a little
bit later but since you just emphasized
the feeling things I thought we'd dive
into this now so you know one of the
things that that a lot of people like
you for and I think a lot of people
criticize you for is some of the trans
stuff now I think we're in complete
agreement on what actual biology is and
you know in that very chair and she sat
on this side once I had Blair white I
wouldn't you're probably familiar right
okay so Blair barest it is it okay so so
Blair is a good friend of mine she just
had dinner here and she look
biologically she is a man and I think
she would more he acknowledges it yes
okay so that's the part that I want to
talk to you about so when I say that
when I say I figured you I figured that
that is why cuz I think you can get to a
place here that might actually be
positive for people that view this both
ways so when I say Xian that I to me
that is I I know this person I respect
this person I like this person and I'm
just showing them a little bit of grace
and dignity to what I'm doing now if the
government but you so you take like the
Jordan Peterson problem in Canada right
if the government was saying to me you
have to use this pronoun right now I
have a major problem with that right but
your knee-jerk response to that is what
where I think the Conservatives maybe
are missing something here and I think
you can bridge the gap and I want to
tell me okay
well that big damn deal so your desire
to say he I just mean that's only
because I'm a public figure meaning that
when we're discussing policy issues in
public and want to discuss some whether
a man is a man or a woman is a woman
which is the reason you're having Blair
on right if Blair we're not discussing
trans issues unless you were talking tax
policy with Blair which is probably a
secondary priority I think then
the reason they're having Blair on is
that you can talk specifically about
these issues and so in the context of
discussing those issues I think that it
is very necessary to draw definitional
lines and that doesn't change based on
who I'm talking to right I mean like I
wouldn't and and there are issues of
self-identity and then there are issues
of what is the definition that we are
currently using like if Rachel Dolezal
we're sitting across from Rachel Dolezal
thinks that Rachel Dolezal is is black
person right right I assume that you
wouldn't say Rachel Dolezal as a black
person in front of Rachel Dolezal just
to make Rachel Dolezal feel better you'd
probably say no your white person why
are you making the argument that your
black person okay so this is where
you're giving me a good dose of ben
shapiro logic so if i was to compare
these two right Rachel Dolezal is white
says she's black no one in their right
mind thinks she's black I don't so this
is so it's I got you your time color by
the way if letters you want to be called
he then I'll just call Blair Blair right
but it but and and I'm happy to do that
in interpersonal relations but but it's
a different thing we're constantly
interacting in the public sphere and so
interacting the public sphere means that
I have to use these definitions because
otherwise the way the game is played is
the minute that I say that Blair White
is she then it's that I'm now
acknowledging that Blair White is a is a
female witch Blair White is not okay so
I'm glad you said that so okay so you're
making a distinction between the public
way we talk about things and sort of
your own private interactions are privy
to your interactions 100% and I think
that's important because that's the part
here where I see this I mean you know
this you know this personally I like we
you and I have talked about public
policy with regard to with regard to the
same-sex marriage you know that when it
comes to same-sex marriage I don't
believe the same sex marriage and
heterosexual marriage are on a par even
though I don't think the government
should be involved in that but I'd have
you and your husband over my house right
I've been in dinner with you in your
house yeah so that it's different
talking about public policy or marriage
accordingly should and it its stellar by
the way being so is your husband medal
so in terms of that part though do you
think it in some way does you a slight
disservice that that you're staking out
a position that I understand why you're
saying it out and also right you're
staking it out sort of because your
enemies will take advantage of it
intellectually honest and I
respect that and I understand that but
the other piece of this to me and maybe
this is where I just still have a little
guilty liberal yeah you know what I mean
perhaps it is but where I see this as
sort of this is just sort of grace and
dignity and and where I want to judge
people as the individual that they are
and and I and I would also like to judge
people obviously as an individual which
is why I say that when we're not in
public setting then you know things may
change but yeah the the entire purpose
of bringing people forward to discuss
trans issues who are trans themselves
the entire intent of doing that is to
prevent you from having an honest
conversation sometimes about the issue
yeah not because the expertise per se
because there plenty of experts on trans
issues who are not themselves trans I
mean they're professors so I think know
a lot more about trans issues than some
of the trans folks people sure are out
there who are making some absurd Clint
and we can argue about the data but
usually the the reason that you have
this argument with somebody who's trans
or a trans advocate who happens to be
trans is specifically so that there is
this element of shame that's injected
into the conversation where if you
really felt that way would you call this
person a he right and the answer is yes
I would call that person to he because
the person is a he like that's not and
that's yeah as you say that's that's
where I think I'm polarizing right
that's where my popularity may come from
in some of these areas and it's also
where my unpopularity may come from in
some of these areas but it's not meant
to be
I'm here to offend you it's we are
literally here discussing the issue of
whether you are a key or a shape right
that is the entire basis of this
conversation is are you a he or a she
yeah and so I'm not going to grant you
the point in the middle of a
conversation about this by giving you
the opposite of what my opinion is on
the issue like that that completely
defeats the purpose of the conversation
right and I do understand that line of
thinking it's just so interesting to me
because you're conceding the fact that
because as a public person you're held
to a different level of honesty or at
least in your own mind right like you're
trying to be honest yeah you try to be
intellectually honest it would be
interesting if we had this conversation
and neither of us were public people at
all if maybe your thoughts on I mean I
think different I think my thoughts
would probably be almost entirely the
same but I think the question is what
level of politeness is necessary for a
public conversation about a public issue
yeah and that's why I don't like the
game that's played by the media this is
the this is the problem that I had with
you know when when I originally wanted
me to prominence was the Piers Morgan
interview yes my problem with Piers
Morgan doing the whole here's a 50
here's a gunshot victim now talk to the
gunshot victim about gun control yeah
and the answer is well why do I have to
talk to a gunshot victim why can't we
just talk about the policy yeah right
whenever a shame tactic is brought into
the conversation as a way to make me not
give my true opinion because I'm
supposed to be ashamed of my true
opinion in front of this person I'm not
ashamed of my opinion and I'll say
exactly what my opinion is in front of
this person and the camera yeah right so
this it changes the conversation
slightly when you're having a public
discussion about a public issue with a
public person yeah how much of this is
just the way that I mean it's that type
of thing that happened with Piers Morgan
that I'm sure most of these people have
seen it's like that the media has used
has used shame it's used sound bites
it's used selective editing all of the
tricks that we know about that you know
you and I are constantly mocking CNN for
that they brought this a brought this
upon themselves I mean they did and it's
and one of the things that I I will
admit I get a kick out of calling out
their [ __ ] on this kind of stuff you
know the when you have the when you have
Jimmy Kimmel bringing out his kid and
using his kid as a lever for his
politics that bothers me no and in the
same way that the gunshot victim bothers
me in the same way that a trans advocate
who may not know that much about actual
biology talking about trans issues but
it's supposed to be from a position of
sympathy the injection of emotion into
political issues does not make things
better it makes things worse typically
yeah right for people that didn't see
your bid on that can you just do like a
quick two minute download on what Kimmel
did and why you thought it was so rude
as I was disgusting I mean well Jimmy
Kimmel who is bi from what I hear I mean
he's for his friends and Adam Carolla
with a guy with him I'm very friendly
you know he's he seems like a nice
person but but what he does is he brings
his his kid into it by suggesting that
his kid who had open-heart surgery at
Children's Hospital with dr. Vaughn
Starnes that his child was a good reason
why Obama care should be upheld in
current form now Jimmy Kimmel doesn't
know anything about Obama care it's
obvious he knows nothing about Obama
care and then after the after the
Republicans were trying to repeal part
of Obamacare then he actually brought
his child on air with him to make the
case that they shouldn't repeal Obama
care and he actually brought his little
kid who's going through surgery now I
have a few problems with this number one
I have two kids who are under the age of
four I would never inject them in a
public conversation ever I don't even
post public pictures of them because I
don't think they should be subjected to
that I think using children like that is
cruel beyond that my daughter had
open-heart surgery at the same hospital
with the same doctor okay and I've never
used that as an excuse for my opinions
on Obamacare because just cuz my
daughter had an experience a medical
experience and thank God by the way
she's totally fine she'll never have to
have another surgery she's great
Stearns is fantastic great hospital but
just because I went through an
experience does not make me an expert on
on public policy like if I were gonna
debate Obamacare I would just tap a nava
Croix at that point like I'd rather be
in somebody who actually studies the
policy and this is one of the things
that drives me nuts is we've reached
such a point we talked at the beginning
about narrative versus facts we've
reached the point where if you have a
narrative on a particular topic this
gives you credibility as opposed to you
have the fact you've studied you've read
a book right if you if you've done any
of those things that's secondary to but
it's not my lived experience well your
lives experience is not statistically
significant sorry to break it to you but
your anecdotal experience in life may
not be a good study an outlier may be an
anomaly or it may be representative I
don't know the answer
but your specific experience well may
tug on my heartstrings I don't know what
that has to say about public policy
decisions we all have to make together
other than attempting to shame me into
feeling bad for you so now I'm supposed
to not look now I'm not an ms-dos kind
of overlook the logical holes in your
argument yeah do you think some of this
is just brain chemistry like that some
of us are simply wired to think the way
you think where you you you sort of want
logic and reason and you want to really
go to it and you'll sort of go where it
gets you where I think most people at
least most people these days are wired
the other way where it's like we're in
this constant state of like what
happened when and where am I supposed to
be outraged like it's actually something
going on in the brain or or it's just
the way we think perhaps I mean I think
I think there's some of both I mean look
I think everyone is drawn to narrative
more than they are drawn to fact they
just as a typical rule I mean this is
why people spend literally hundreds of
dollars a year going to movies okay this
is why I really could have done three
hours a night and I would have preferred
it right also rather talk with you a
narrative story because it's fun to talk
about narrative story and it's more
engaging it's why people love the Trump
reality show because it's more narrative
story than it is necessarily like the
amount of time that you are I spend
talking about the actual policy in and
outs of the tax reform its give me a lot
less than the amount of time we spend on
Trump's Twitter feed right because
narrative is just more interesting to
human beings than anything else that's
just the way it is but the question is
when it comes time for us to make good
decisions about our own
I'm more concerned about the narrative
of the grocer and what he's gone through
are we more interested in the price of
the the box of cereal and so we're gonna
need to make these decisions on public
policy by moving the narrative out of
the way and so I've spent a lot of my
time trying to separate the two trying
to say okay listen I can tell you
stories too we can do stories all day
long but I don't think it gets us
anywhere this is why I hate when people
say well you're denying my lived
experience or denying my experience I'm
not denying your experience I'm denying
that your experience is representative
of the public policy that we should
follow yeah this is why whenever I say
what I'm talk about police bias for
example and somebody says well you're
denying that I've been discriminated
against by the police no you may very
well have been discriminated against by
the police I don't know I wasn't there I
don't have all the records I don't have
it on tape I don't know what the cop was
doing five minutes before and five
minutes after I don't know whether he
just a jackass to everyone and you
happen to be black like I don't know any
of that but I do know that these
statistical that the statistics show
that the number of arrest reports
directly correlate with the number of
arrests with the suspect descriptions
being reported by people who have
actually been victimized by crime which
suggests to me that there is no wild
disproportion between who the cops are
looking for and what they are told to
look for by the victims of crime right
so but people don't want to hear that
right when you say that then it's not
well no you're saying that I really
wasn't that I've never experienced this
again you may very well have experienced
or you know we live in a subjective
world maybe it's possible you
misinterpreted events mm-hmm right then
that's always one that we never want to
think about maybe we just misinterpreted
the event that we were that we were a
part of maybe it wasn't that the cop was
discriminatory maybe it's the cops a
jerk maybe he's having a bad day right
maybe he's maybe he's that way to
everyone right we think we can know the
absolute truth about all of these
stories all the time and when we find
one that doesn't fit our narrative we
ignore that one that's one of the most
interesting things that I think the
media does now where they pick which
stories to ignore as much as the ones
they decide to blow up and it's like
that is a version of fake news - I
totally agree like it take perfect
example right the media will focus
endlessly about Michael Brown but
there's that horrible story at that
hotel and trailer here was where the cop
legitimately gunned down a guy who I
mean it's it's crazy it's a white guy
cuz there was it so it's a white guy so
instead of us have our Kelly Thomas out
here in California or in the homeless
man who's beaten to death by the cops
right instead of us having a
conversation about whether maybe we have
a problem if we do have a problem at the
police maybe the problem with the police
is in generalized training to respond to
crisis scenarios and
that it turns into a nonce endemic of
American racism going back to slavery
and said well show me the data and then
we can have a conversation but don't
give me tonic he see Coates talking
points about black bodies and tell me
that that's an argument because it's not
it's interesting because the the one you
mentioned in the hallway with the cop
from just two months ago or so I mean
it's a flat-out execution it is I mean
for people that haven't seen it I don't
know that you should watch it cuz it's
pretty horrible to watch but it's like
what I wonder on a story like that cuz
you're right it didn't catch the
national narrative the way it should
it's like look somebody at CNN saw that
so how does that not then get to I'm
just picking somebody how does that not
get to Jake Tapper for example and he's
like let's show it now maybe he did yeah
I don't know it's a portion yet support
ween the coverage of that and the
reaction to that so what I mean what do
you talk that up to us someone that's
the editor-in-chief of the site it's not
as narrative ly interesting the
narrative that's being pushed by the
left is that the cops are racist and
they're shooting black people
disproportionately but do you think
that's just sort of collective hive mind
at these organizations like they just
hire people that sort of they know
ideologically buy into all of that I
mean they know it gets ratings they know
what's interesting it's not as
interesting a story cops do something
wrong is not as interesting a story as
racist cops gunned down black man yeah
and also they know that the response
from the public is not quite the same
right when a white guy gets shot before
by the police for unjustified reasons
because there is no long racial history
of white people beating on white people
I mean that there the truth is there is
right a massive majority of white people
who are murdered murdered by white
people but but because there is no long
contentious racial history among whites
in the same way there is between whites
and black people that they know that if
the stories like that's on the evening
news there are gonna be a hundred
thousand people in the streets
protesting that or ten thousand or five
thousand or a hundred protesting that in
Orange County for any severe length of
time but if in Ferguson if they tell
that story for two days there's gonna be
a full-scale riot and then they can
bring the camera to the riot so I don't
think that it's I don't think it's quite
as malicious as Nightcrawler I don't
think it's like they're they're trying
to set up the scenario just so they can
cover the aftermath yeah but I think
that there is a sense in which they feel
like it is more newsworthy if it's more
likely to lead to a conflagration and so
that actually becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy right now it's more newsworthy
because more likely to lead to a
conflagration then they're more likely
to cover it leading to a conflagration
which makes it more newsworthy which
makes it more likely to lead to a
conflagration so this is this thing is
just constantly feeding itself basic
and everyone wants these clicks and all
that how do you as someone that not only
is doing your own show but you're the
editor-in-chief of the site you've got
many writers now and you guys just got
new offices and you have show you know a
fuse month yes you guys are doing great
how do you manage to not become part of
the problem in that I mean it's hard
because there's stuff that people want
to click on and people and some people
don't
I mean you try to exercise as much
editorial discretion as possible so I
will knock down stories that I think are
not completely newsworthy or that I
think are badly badly sourced but I
think that you know as a conservative
site a lot of what we do is counter
narrative so a lot of what we do is
cover in CNN covering a story wrong
mm-hmm right a lot of what we will do is
point out the hypocrisy won't cover like
we have a guy a couple guys on staff
we're obsessed with Las Vegas shootings
and they'll keep coming back to why the
media just completely forgotten about
the war shooting in America it's very I
mean clearly forgot about it we had
about three days of it nobody's still
clear on almost anything there's been
almost no video stories in shifting we
don't know even what happened inside the
hotel like who got shot it's it's the
whole what does that say about you think
that's just Twitter generation like our
attention spans are so short I mean our
attention span is definitely short like
that I got one of these notes about one
of my videos being too long the other
day but the video is 68 seconds we're in
a lot of trouble yeah exactly let it sit
but ID is attention span stuff and some
of it is just what what catches your eye
and what people click on and there is a
disconnect between what people are
interested in and necessarily what is I
think in a more objective sense
newsworthy yeah I mean what's going on
in Iran is a lot more newsworthy than
what's going on you know in in Donald
Trump's Twitter feed with North Korea
obviously but the coverage has been not
proportionate yeah so I actually want to
touch on both of those so let's jump to
Iran first one of the things on the
media front of this is that it's
becoming pretty obvious that the
BuzzFeed's of the world and HuffPo and
CNN and and much to my chagrin the New
York Times they're sort of all
pro-regime right now it's pretty insane
yeah they're actually against the people
and who's for the people suddenly it's
those evil Republicans those evil
conservatives you guys are suddenly all
for freedom of all of these people but I
thought you were the bad guy yeah I
think there are two things that are
happening that are that are both really
egregious one is that anything Trump
does must be evil right and and
conversely that anything Obama did must
be great right and because one of
Obama's agenda items was making Iran a
regional power then we have to defend
his agenda at all cost the only way to
do that is to say that the regime was
never fragile right because then it
would be on Obama to try to push it over
the regime was always gonna be there was
always durable it's just a question of
trying to moderate them and that's what
Obama was trying to do
so if Trump would just try to moderate
them instead of instead of trying to
push them then things would all be
better why doesn't he just shut up right
so that's that's angle number one yeah
well number two there's patently a lie
it's all monster did you see that tweet
from John Brennan the former CIA head
basically he was saying well look this
is because of the way Trump acted for
the last year if we would have only let
the moderates do their thing the
moderates never do their thing I mean
the other thing we should intervene I'm
just saying let the people the moderates
were legitimately shooting people in the
streets in 2009 right I mean well at the
same time that that Obama was talking
about Hassan rouhani was a moderate
there was the new moderate regime he's
lying the American people blatantly
right I mean who Ben Rhodes admitted
they were lying to the American people
blatantly about Iran nuclear deal
they're shooting Netta in the streets at
the same time so that the whole thing is
crazy but that's that's that's number
one number two there's always been this
aspect of the far left I don't want to
attribute it to the entire left piece I
think it allow liberals who don't feel
this way but there are a few people on
the hard left who actually believe that
America is in nefarious negative force
in the world and so that means the
Iranians are just the Iranian government
is standing up to this brutal regime so
when you see I telecom any tweeting out
black lives matters talking points what
she did literally literally tweeted out
about how you as a police force to shoot
men women and children who are black for
no reason at all anything well that
sounds an awful lot like leaders of BLM
suppose he knows that they're a bunch of
people in the United States who are
happy to crap all over the legacy of the
United States and suggest that Trump
regime Trump is going to be just like
regime Iran all these people who are
marching the streets wearing handmade
tails outfit it say these are the people
who drive me up a freakin wall I didn't
vote for Trump right I was in supportive
of Trump during the election cycle it
doesn't matter
to suggest that we are like on the verge
of Mike Pence making some woman of Mike
and then dressing her in that crazy
outfit and that we're about to become
Iran they're analysts on the far left
who are suggesting this sort of thing
and then they say okay well then Trump
can't talk because I mean look how
terrible things are here and even pee
I respect like Maggie Haberman who is I
think it's very good reporter at The New
York Times Maggie Haberman tweeted out
something out I'm not sure she meant to
do it she sort of clarified later but
what she originally tweeted out this is
the Trump the Trump walking thing on
Twitter right where there was where the
Trump had tweeted out that Iran is
legitimately blocking Twitter and
Facebook and all social media across
Iran they're blocking an internet sites
across Iran to prevent the dissemination
of information as a Maggie Hammond
tweeted out the Trump had blocked a few
people from the real Donald Trump
account yeah and I'd tweet out like
these are not alike in any way like what
did why is I don't like the Trump blocks
people I don't even black people on
Twitter right I have new people on why
do black people feel you're oh yeah I
don't block them because you know if
they want it I think mute is much more
frustrating to them frankly like if they
can see me and they think they're
tweeting at me and then I care yeah it's
a I just enjoy the idea of them
furiously tweeting in the middle of the
night and I have no I can't see it I do
like that one to my policy on the block
though is sometimes people are dedicated
to just fighting with people who are
trying to have an option so that's the
only way you can really remove them from
blocking people either President of the
United States you should probably a
better things to do it's not something
that I'm a big fan of but to equate him
blocking some people he doesn't like on
Twitter who can legitimately just open
an incognito window or go to Google and
just Twitter Google Trump's account and
equating that with Iran shutting down
the Internet is totally insane yeah did
you see the one from Samantha power also
yeah and that was another doozy implying
that you know well Trump doesn't want to
let any of these people in here in the
hope that there's literally I mean per
guy who like logic this is a jump that's
just a bit well I mean not only is it a
jump it's a backwards jump right means
she's actually leaping backwards because
the whole point of changing Iranian
policy so people don't want to leave and
come here that's the whole reason if you
want to knock over the regimes that
there's a better regime in place that
people are not coming here and we don't
have to deal with an influx of people we
can't vet then it seems to me that Trump
should be doing exactly what he's doing
Samantha power should be willing to talk
straight to book about genocide and then
overseas one engine in Syria and it's
just it's all insipid so when we do the
foreign policy thing I think this is
where you and I have a bit of a
difference of opinion I for me I'm more
I'm not I'm not purely an isolationist
and I believe in strong defense so that
we don't have to use it would be my
general policy I believe in a big stick
that's it but I don't think we should I
don't think we should be doing regime
change I don't I wait are you
for the US I mean I'm not sure invasion
of Iran yeah I'm for doing whatever we
can covertly to knock over the regime I
mean it's basically helping the the
popular upper so my feeling is we should
forward American interests by any means
necessary and sometimes those means are
too costly and sometimes those means are
not too costly and that's that's a
calculation they have to go in a
case-by-case basis but America as the
most moral force on planet earth
whatever we do to pursue our interests
and preserve our strengths and those are
sometimes at odds
yeah are is something that we should do
so I'm not like for example I was not in
favor of the invasion of Libya I was not
in favor of getting deeply involved in
Syria in the first place I was critical
of President Obama for for you know the
implication that he was going to get
involved in Syria and really see what
our interest was there the same thing is
certainly true of Libya so I'm not full
bush you know kind of conservative wing
that's that's I'm more of a realist than
I think what do you make of the fact
that we do these things like Libya which
we call the kinetic military action no
one had even ever heard of that before
but suddenly kinetic military action or
Syria where it's obviously a war but we
don't never declare a war anymore we've
seated all of this power I mean I use
the War Powers Act I think the Congress
should come back in and vote I think I'm
on Rand Paul side of that even if I'm
not on his side generally with regard to
foreign policies so yeah but has the
ship sailed on all of that stuff so like
we can discuss this intellectually and
Rand Paul can keep fighting for it and
keep losing but like is it really over
yeah I mean dancing the way they're sent
over I mean Trump campaign basically is
a neo isolationist in many ways and then
he's basically governing like Bush on
foreign policy right I mean his foreign
policy looks a lot more bushy in yeah
then it looks well I think you can be a
cannon you could probably make the same
argument for Obama that he actually has
ever and in a lot of ways like Bush like
we did tons of things all over the world
and kicked a lot of people out of the
country and all sorts of things I mean I
think I think a lot of this sounds a lot
easier in philosophy than it is in
practice I mean I'm assuming that they
get some information from military Intel
that that suggested that there's a
higher risk of danger that requires
military intervention I don't I don't
think it's that everyone who steps in
the Oval Office is shot in the butt with
a Woodrow Wilson
you know injection and suddenly and
suddenly you want to invade everywhere
right it's just it's just for me I guess
it's the idea that if any country if
haneda tomorrow put two ships or forget
chips if they started a lot launching a
couple of rockets from you know Toronto
into Detroit we would say it's an act of
war even if it wasn't the government it
was like some you know some offshoot
group there so it's like if we park
boats outside of Syria and we're
shooting things in and drop and drowning
and all that we're being honest here
you're right it's clearly war I mean the
only question is is whether that's in
our interest or not because the question
of what is a declared war versus a not
declared war that ship sailed a long
time ago because now that we've
basically declared everything the
president does an exigent circumstance
then everything is immediate and
necessary we have to fire first and and
Congress gets to ask questions later
even the War Powers Resolution suggests
that you know there's a 60-day period
where the president can do what he wants
before Congress even gets to cut off
funds and intervene basically right you
know that's I think unfortunately the
the legislative impact on war-making
power has basically gone by the wayside
yeah this is where the libertarians just
could never get it together right like
if they would have and we would have
cared about the separation of powers and
all that that things would be a little
bit different yeah I mean I think that
again most Americans and this is just a
general movement have signed off on the
idea that if the government is doing
something they like they don't care how
the government goes about doing it and
that's that's a real problem i I see
very few people who are honest enough to
say even if the government is doing
something I like if I don't like how
they are doing it then I'm not willing
to go along with it that's the the means
actually matter here but not for most
people I think do you think the reverse
of that is actually starting to become
true where I see this new collection of
people that were sort of in this mix
this twenty or thirty people do in kind
of what we're doing where it's like I
think people what people like about it
they see we're at least trying to be
intellectually honest we will make
mistakes we will get things wrong people
will love to call us out on those rings
you know I hope that when we get things
wrongly we correct them and apologize
for them you know absolutely but but do
you think that actually people want that
I mean it shows your rise in this past
year was so you know you've been doing
this for a long time on yeah but
something happened in 2017 and I think
it was directly because people are sick
of the nonsense like they actually want
and no one's giving it to man mainstream
so they'll go to Joe Rogan and Sam
Harris who have many different views
that you have and then they'll come to
me and go
to sargon of akkad or whoever it's very
weird I mean the coalition of people who
they place together in sort of the
honest broker category it's a very
eclectic group of folks right I may not
agree like it's pretty cool right it's
really neat it's really neat and I like
that a lot and I do agree with you I
think that if I had to chalk up sort of
what's happened over the last year in
terms of my brand to to anything it's
that I hope I've tried to be as
intellectually honest as possible
especially in the era when everybody
seems to be doing the Rob Rob Roy Ellis
routine you know I I coined a good trump
bad Trump which is now become a thing
yeah I mean we had a jingle halfway
through 2013 so the the idea that we're
trying to at least give you my honest
take on the issues and I'll be honest
and upfront about my biases I think
that's that's something that people
appreciate it's true for you too I mean
obviously they're people I've almost
separated the media into two groups
people who try on people who don't and
it doesn't matter if I agree with them
if there are people who I think are
trying like they're at least trying to
look beyond their own knee-jerk reaction
to events toward what are the facts on
the ground and then make a decision then
I give them credit for that even if we
disagree which is why I can have a
really good conversation with Sam Harris
and we agree about nothing on religion
or atheism and we could have a really
cordial conversation specifically about
those issues because we will acknowledge
I think both what is what is fact and
what is not fact even if we disagree on
the conclusions we reach from that yeah
all right so I wanna I want to get into
a little bit of what you and Sam did and
he just goes on yeah he just posted the
audio on Monday so hopefully some people
that are watching subsea knit already
but I want you to do a little psychology
on me for a moment all right you made a
comment you got the mark hamill going on
yeah young young Mark Hamill hold Mark
Hamill young Mark Hamill better than old
grumpy Luke but that are separate yeah
so before you made a distinction which I
always try to make between you know the
hard left and those sort of modern left
and live liberals yeah and you know that
I've hung my hat on this classical
liberal idea in a way do you think that
like I feel like where I'm getting to
and maybe it's gonna hit me in this next
year is that I think I've done a nice
job of trying to clean up what's going
on on the left and I think I've helped
some of the liberals kind of escape
leftism and some of that stuff but it's
pretty obvious to me at this point that
even for the disagreements that we may
have that my allies in this space
basically are mostly conservatives
really for me more libertarians
this point and I'm using a definition of
liberalism which although correct that
classical liberalism is about the
individual and all that I'm using a
definition from say 1940 we're now even
if I'm a hundred percent right that I'm
sort of swimming in a thing that I can't
get out of here and I'm like yeah yeah I
guess you feel that too as I think it's
true that you you know in in a certain
way have swum over to a side that you've
that you weren't intending to I mean by
trying to be intellectually honest and
by trying to say that you are for the
individual and not the collective this
has brought you to a couple of places
one away from the left and - you've been
embraced by a couple of groups on the
right one is the group of people who I
hope are intellectually honest and say
we have a lot in common because even if
we disagree on specific policy we all
agree that the individual is the essence
of the modern world
yeah but the but I think that there is
what we'll yell we all have to be
careful of is the reactionary bent on
both sides of our politics which says ok
Dave Rubin used to be on the left and
now he's hitting the left and that means
I love Dave Rubin yeah right and and the
same thing is true for me from the left
right because I wasn't sued because I
wasn't very Pro Trump and that meant
that there were a bunch of people who
are on the Left were like suddenly oh
I'll take a look at your peer and say
well and then they're surprised when I'm
conservative and say well I didn't
change really like you're just you're
perceiving the world through a prism
that seems slightly flawed yeah in the
same way that I think a lot of people on
the right perceive the world through the
prism of the anti Left which is a
distinction that I'm I don't like I
don't think that conservative an anti
laughter at the same thing this is a
major point that I've been making
recently and a ton of just because of
the way the online media world works I
mean it was Rush Limbaugh who I love and
who is the granddaddy of talk radio and
all of that rush changed the name of the
advanced Institute for conservative
studies to the advanced Institute for
anti left studies in the middle of last
year's election cycle and I thought or
two years ago election cycle now and I
thought that's not a change for the
positive I don't think that's I don't
think that's a good thing I think the
conservatism and anti left are not the
same thing the Nazis were anti laughs
they were not conservative yeah there's
there's a there's a big difference and
you know by the same token I think that
the the left has now decided to recast
the world purely in terms of Trump so in
so if you're anti Trump this means
you're an ally now right it's like well
so Romney now is an ally even though
Jeff Flake Jeff Flake loads with from 95
percent of the time but he's an ally of
the left now because he's critical of
how Trump tweets and say if that's your
prism I would humbly suggest that you
really need to get a new prism because
your prism sucks it really does suck I
mean you could even tell because now
it's pretty obvious that Romney's gonna
run for Senate in Utah and he changed
his Twitter location and all that and
it's like they hated him before binders
full of women he's a rich elitist about
but now because he hates Trump the
media's gonna love him exact and it's
even right now just as we're doing this
right now there's all this stuff
breaking about Bannon and Trump hates
Bannon now and I bet you what's gonna
happen over the next component I mean
she'll start interviewing Bannon yeah
absolutely absolutely can make it you
can make a cottage industry out of being
david brock in this particular
environment right yes flip sides and
boom like it would not fully surprise me
if steve Bannon were campaigning for
bernie sanders next year so bad because
that's the dynamic of our politics now
is people ping-pong in from one side to
the other
just off of the reactionary nature of
each side right and we're basically
fighting like like a terminator from t2
right like we're fighting this thing
that's constantly morphing in front of
us because we're trying to basically you
know right stay ourselves stay within
something this thing's just changing at
every moment because it has it's not
based in reality I think that's also why
you know not for us to be arrogant I
think that's why we're doing well is it
feels like people are looking for things
to grab onto and an environment where
everything is liquid metal and moving
the whole around you that you know the
fact that there are a few poles of
gravity people say okay here's where I
stand and guess what where I stand has
not changed and it's not going anywhere
I have exactly the same positions that I
had six months ago and doesn't matter
that the politics around me has shifted
I think my ideas are correct I think
people can gravitate to that because it
gives them something to hold on to what
people are looking for is some sort of
port in what is a chaotic political
storm at this point yeah it's so funny
because I truly and I say this all the
time it's like I just think I'm doing a
little common sense stuff yeah like I I
actually don't think it's much more than
that
I do like talking to people and my mind
is still flexible and you know you've
been able to shift me on a couple things
and hopefully I've been able to ship you
on a couple things I still think I can
get you on this pronoun thing a little
bit more it doesn't happen that have to
happen right now but what I by the way
on the pronoun thing I mean I did an
interview with a guy who is on the left
and what I said is if you want to come
up with a third pronoun I'm happy to use
that third pronoun
I'm just not happy to use he for a sheet
and chief or he right so if you want to
come up with a trans pronoun
Yeah right where where this identifies
your gender then you know if you want to
say that you are a biological he buddy
but you identify as a sheet that's
really really long like all I asked is a
little bit of specificity don't don't
muddy the terminology is my thing there
I mean the last thing I want is more
words and labels and everything else
yeah sure enough the labels have any
meaning I mean I know we have to keep
saying these things and you have to say
conservative is this and I'm talking
about classical liberalism and all that
but it's all of that just out the window
at this point because so much is being
realigned I think that it's out the
window insofar as people have
misinterpreted what the labels mean yeah
right so if you if by conservative you
think everything Trump says then that's
not conservative if you think by liberal
you're talking about everything that
Cornel West thinks right then that's not
liberal right so it's so it the
terminology is helpful only insofar as
it has a set meaning and this is what's
hard right now is that people keep
shifting the meaning every five minutes
of these terms and it's really difficult
to follow so that's why you know the
fact that you're on so often and talking
softened by your principles it's easier
for people I think to actually identify
with I agree with the politics of so and
so than it is to say I'm a conservative
or a liberal because those terms are
shifting and I've done pretty regular
basis now is there anyone that you see
on the broader left were more
specifically on the Democrat side that
you think like what happened to the Blue
Dog Democrats or just like is there
anyone that you think is moderate left
there because I would love to support
that person if that if that person you
know if JFK was still alive I'm sure I
would be a JFK's board if Daniel Patrick
Moynihan was still around I would I
would support him that there's virtually
none of those people laugh at I wish
they were there that I that's where my
home should be well the state said the
states have polarized so much now that
no elected official is basically from a
purple area right I mean the number of
purple Democrats is really really low I
think that there may be a couple there's
a couple from Ohio there's there's a
military guy from Massachusetts who I
think may be slightly more moderate but
on the Democratic side but well I knew
it was over was the first debate when
Jim Webb was still running the Galliani
and Hillary and it was as if it was as
if he came it out of a time machine not
oh there yeah the thing we're the thing
where he said that he idea that he'd
kill communists
which I was like all right okay
and then everybody unless like oh yeah
well that was a communist trying to kill
him in a jungle like he's supposed to
dude
dad I thought and Jim Webb looked around
like it was so funny cuz Jim Webb looks
around triumphantly like he knows he got
off a good line yeah and he did in 1984
Yeah right in 1984 in a democratic
debate he got off a great line in 2016
and democratic debate he got off the
worst line and could possibly get off it
was not empathetic and it didn't
recognize the value of multiculturalism
it was a little racist and he looks
around and Elson you could see it dawn
on him I am in the wrong bar is that it
was that scene from Blues Brothers were
there play playing the wrong dive bar
yeah that I mean to me that may have
been the moment that I finally realized
like how this thing had shifted
massively whether I want whether I did
or not like the fact that that was
thought that this guy was thought of as
the fringe guy really shows you how much
this is there was a chart if you've seen
these charts that they make of how the
political partisan moves and they sort
of have these over flow charts they they
look like kind of bell curves and so
they'll narrow or they'll broaden and
what it shows is that since like 2008
the only thing that's happened is the
Democratic Party's move left so it shows
the right kind of moving to the right
slowly up till about 2008 2010 and then
it shows the left going Shoop just way
off the charts on the Left yeah and so
you've seen this polarization in the
parties that's been pretty radical it's
interesting because I know that some
people watching this will say no it's
the reverse the right has gotten more
right the right got more right up till
about 2010 right at the tea party at the
point of the tea party that's his right
as they want and then it's been stagnant
since 2010 right soon from 2010 to 2011
in the Republican Party all the movement
has been in the Democratic Party if
anything I think you could argue that
the right has actually become more
Center I mean literally nobody is
arguing against gay rights anymore right
right like Ted Cruz does there's more in
more libertarian direction a lot of
social issues I think if these polls
Republicans now on pot right the number
of Republicans who don't care about pot
anymore is really high yeah sessions is
one pot I'm I'm fine with
decriminalization I don't care yeah I
mean I think that people who smoke pot
are wasting their time I hate the smell
of it and I wish we do it away from me
but it's I know it's but it's but you
know my view on this has always been the
same which is the government sucks at
everything they couldn't even keep pot
off the playground when I was in sixth
grade so obviously there their efforts
have been for not yeah
and decriminalization and heavy taxation
seems like about if you want to restrict
it seems like a better plan to me then
than anything else although if you tax
it too much then you get a black market
anyway so yeah I mean as you can
probably tell them for decriminalization
I just think the government has nothing
to do with it and they couldn't do it
well anyway and guess what everyone
especially in this state you know I went
and I told the guy my shoulder hurt and
I got you know like oh yeah I mean four
years right I mean and say you just walk
in like all my back hurts I thought well
Patil solve that yeah
and gangrene panel solve that as a the
magic it's like pepto it'll solve it it
is amazing I do love when people say
well it's organic it's from the ground
like cancer is organic to like a but I'm
not comparing a potted to cancer but
well we ordered I know which thing will
be quick you know wrongfully quoted at
exactly now we know but I'm pretty
criminalization people and I do you get
conservatives that give you [ __ ] for
that opinion because I think the
conservative movements kind of split on
this really I mean because again on a
personal level I think that can be like
communities ought to fight the use of
pot by teenagers because I think that it
is not good for teenagers I've never
seen a teenager who's better off for
smoking pot yeah unless you're talking
about like a terminally ill teenager who
has no author or something but that's
not what we're talking about yeah but
you know I think that because most
conservatives understand that what I've
basically advocated for is conservatism
in the social sphere away from
government but government getting out of
everything yeah then I'm not advocating
against social standards I'm just saying
the social standard should be informal
and community driven they should not be
driven by a massive government
infrastructure that is pointing the gun
at somebody yeah all right so let's back
up for a second so you did this event in
San Francisco it was sam Harris's
podcast and invite man yeah so it was it
was actually so I was there and we all
hung out before and I was very secretly
jealous that I was not on stage with you
got oh yeah that was been fun but it's
alright but it was really interesting
evening because Sam sort of had to play
moderator and tyrol and panelists right
and and Eric was Eric and I think in
most places Eric Weinstein is sort of a
bridge between you guys because
especially on the religious stuff which
he has a sort of I think Corsi
spirituality is not a believer in a
traditional sense so that's you know
more like Sam and yet he has a certain
affinity force even practices I think in
some level and that's more in line with
you
so I just thought it was a great couple
hours Sam just put the podcast up we'll
put the link down below
I don't want to relitigate the whole
thing but I'm curious on on a couple
points when you talk about religion
mm-hmm
I've never seen you try to push religion
on anyone yes I think yeah I've never
seen it at all do you enjoy that
conversation no because to me you're a
political beast
yeah that's what I kept thinking when
when you when there was like an hour on
religion I was like I was like been kind
of really shines that rally at politics
and I was kind of wondering do you
actually really want to do that publicly
because it's not something you're trying
to to spread to them so I'm happy to
talk about it because I think that it's
interesting and I think it goes to
deeper issues and it's fun you're um you
know because it's not it's kind of
effervescent is politics and there's not
there's never a headline to peg it to so
politics is always like Trump tweeted
something exciting today right religion
is like the problem of theodicy has
anyone thought about it except for every
religious think of for the last 3,000
years so you're always rehashing
philosophies that are a thousand years
old I mean in whatever the context are
you gonna be quoting Aristotle on a
regular basis about the unmoved mover
you know something that's written at
least 25 25 hundred years ago or
whatever nice yeah so that's that's 2300
years ago so in any case that's a it
always puts you in a slightly more
boring territory just to talk about that
topic but I do enjoy talking about it
because I think that it's a it goes to a
lot of route issues in how people think
that they really have not thought about
before I think a lot of people don't
take the most logically consistent
positions with regard to even their own
belief systems with regard to religion
and with regard to how religion mixes
with values and defines values so this
was one of the points of contention with
Sam was there was one point when I said
to him you know your values are based on
my values and he said no they're not I
said well you grew up in North Hollywood
like five miles from me I promise you
you know you grew up in the same milieu
you grew up in the same society that's
based on certain Enlightenment notions
that are based in turn on certain
notions of God and reason that are
inherent in both judeo-christian values
and Greek thought and if you wanna be an
atheist that's totally fine but you do
have to recognize the implications of
the atheism so yeah that's that's an
area where I'm I'm pretty passionate
about that because I think that again
I'm not trying to make Sam believe
anything Sam can believe whatever he
wants and I also don't believe that you
have to be a religious person to be a
good person
I think acting well is what's more
important to me than believing like I
believe I'm always an action driven
person
so I driven person right so at the
individual
you don't believe that you have to base
it on base your beliefs or
judeo-christian values but you think at
a societal level that you think we have
to wear that we're just doing it I do
you think you have to I think that if
you're gonna peg morality to anything
beyond what you feel like today then
you're going to have to at some point
arrive at an objective sense of where
that morality comes from so whether you
base that on the notion of Revelation
and the judeo-christian tradition or
whether you base that on the basic
notions of teleology from Greek
tradition the notion of a Tilos and that
the in that the universe is created in a
certain way so that we can discover its
meaning and therefore we know that a
glass is for drinking from and we know
that good human being is for reasoning
or any sort of the Aristotelian notion
then the the you're gonna have to base
it on something something either
discoverable and objective in nature or
not and so what I was trying to push Sam
on was where are you getting the notions
that underpin your morality right it's
like I I agree with Sam that there's a
possibility I would say significant
possibility that we live in a meeting a
Lewis universe where balls would meet
with no free well like I won't say that
that's not a possibility because I think
that is a possibility
yeah but what I will say is that you
cannot build any sort of morality as a
society on the basis of that you might
be able to to come up with some
interesting ways of finding morality for
yourself but I would say this that the
Tam's morality which values the same
things that I value as a general matter
I find it weird that he comes to the
same conclusions that I do for the most
part on what is good and what is bad
morally but he just did it from from
what pure reason which doesn't exist in
the world of free well you know like the
the idea of a self willed person making
moral decisions does not exist in a
world where your Spinoza's you know meat
ball flying through the universe with a
little bit of self-awareness so in
effect a self willed person again a
micro-level is fine but the macro is
just the over time you just feel I mean
this is our audience tells I had Prager
I had Prager and Michael Shermer on yes
I watch this very issue as passing
that's where I think it got to the most
meat that that again they're both
individualist also which is interesting
so it's like at the individual level you
can figure out a way to live well and
good and morally and all of that the
carrion stayed yeah I mean I think that
you can what I don't know and I still am
waiting to hear a good answer on
is in a world where we are just a glomer
ation of cells and environment with no
capacity for free choice how do you make
a moral decision where does where does
morality even come into it look and it
was interesting I thought the best of
the best moment of the debate really
with more discussion than the debate was
at the very end when a woman got up and
asked Sam you know I agree with
everything you say I have a
five-year-old son what do I teach him
it's him basically I mean to boil it
down Sam basically said lie to him right
Sam basically said I actually don't
remember what the others he essentially
said lied to him eBay and maybe maybe
sample dispute that and I don't want to
put words and Sam's me let's go listen
to it but my impression the takeaway was
Sam basically said well you can't really
teach him he has no control over his
life and no free will
so you should probably tell him that he
should make good choices and I thought
well now you're talking my language
right you don't get to burn down my
house and then use the place for my
house to build your own floor yeah I
think this also get not I think I know
this gets a little bit into the nuance
of the freewill argument and where you
guys obviously disagree and I think his
visit freewill is more honest than the
compatibilist position and there are
people who say they'd the compatible is
compatible this position we're on free
will which is yes we're all a bunch of
biological functions and we don't have a
any sort of capacity to control overcome
that but somehow we still it Freebo I
think that's crap and I think Sam does a
good job of debunking that but the
problem is once you once you've debunked
it where do you go from here right so
his point on freewill basically would be
if I say to you name a color blue what
right did you just do that yourself was
that your free will that did that or was
it the everything that led you right a
very moment the primordial ooze all of
your experiences all of that you said
blue right and then in my and my answer
is I don't know the answer to that I
believe you know in sort of the William
James proposition I choose to believe I
guess yeah in the in the ability to
choose right and so the idea here would
be I chose blue it depends on the level
of choice to I think a little more
complex than that I don't think I choose
to you know scratch my head in the same
way that I choose to marry my wife
mm-hmm I think that these is the Daniel
Kahneman a you know who thinks of the
kind of fast systems of thinking and the
slow systems of thinking he talks about
how slow systems are thinking involved
more well and kind of in himself says
you sort of have to believe in free will
in order to believe in in any capacity
for self change and I've seen too many
people change I've seen see I mean
you're in the
of changing people this is the thing
about about the the freewill debate that
I find so puzzling if you really don't
believe in free will if you really
believe that it's just all the things
that happened throughout history to lead
you here if you had LaCrosses demon
right that could reconstruct every
element of the universe and therefore
decide when you're gonna sneeze if you
really have that then what was the point
of having the debate in San Francisco
like did people just randomly show up
there and I randomly showed up there and
we all had a debate and we enjoyed
ourselves and it wouldn't matter if
you'd wanted to not show up there
wouldn't have been that once and then
want never would have existed there is
no choice to be otherwise like what do
you do with your life when you feel like
you are just there right here you're
this glass or you're that bottle that's
just that you have an awareness that
your glass or a bottle right so I don't
want to speak for Sam but I think he
would say that that's not exactly what
his position is that he's still in
control of all of those things but that
behind-the-scenes guy didn't like that
phrase either but yeah this is the point
I think it's true Dawkins too and
whenever you talk about The Selfish Gene
when you talk that there's there's a
language of purpose that's constantly
being used by Daniel Dennett's or
Dawkins and kind of that nature has a
purpose or that the gene has a purpose
or it's all those purpose purpose of
language mm-hmm and that's a hallmark of
my system of thought then you're not
hijacking and using for your system and
that's the part that I find really I
think it's it's a disconnect and I think
that when it's applied broadly it's you
it's very difficult not to become a sort
of Sartre existential existentialist
except without starts belief that you
can like the thing about existential
with belief you know through through
Sartre at least is that in in the end
you can cry out against the the
meaninglessness of the universe but I
don't know how you can cry out against
the meaninglessness of the universe if
you are destined to either cry or not so
the beauty of it is that you described
it you said debate and then you pause
and said conversation and that really
was what it was and and you're right
there was a sense of mutual respect up
there I'll let people is do it I do want
to ask you one other thing the event
which is that we mentioned Eric briefly
and that he sort of splits the
difference I think between you guys do
you think that that position makes sense
someone that can say sort of on the
intellectual side I am NOT a believer in
a traditional sense but that I see all
of the value that religion or tradition
or whatever you want to call it has
brought and I'll try to incorporate that
so I think this is a yeah I think
there's a perfectly honest position I've
said for a long time that if you're an
atheist but you recognize what
judeo-christian values have brought to
your world and that they provide the
foundation upon which you stand we have
very little argue about you know III
think that if you recognize that there
is a system of thought that you are
basing your own system of thought on and
you say I disagree with a lot of the
fundamental premises of that but I can
pick out the good parts right then then
at least that's that's honest and I
think that where I have a problem is you
know some of the more militant language
about you know all religious belief
being inherently harmful or all
religious belief being equal or all
religions being equal yeah like that
that I thought I don't know does that do
that but there are people who are who
sort of do that and they'll say anybody
who's promulgating religion even
moderate religion that makes people's
lives better is really just chilling for
the man basically yeah and I think that
that's not only a problem I think that
that takes the heart out of us aside
yeah I don't think increased secularism
in Europe has been particularly good for
the the forward-leaning growth of that
continent in that the continents
grumbling yes and I think those things
are not unrelated I think that I think
there is I think religion without
religion without reason
turns into tyranny and reason without
religion completely collapses in on
itself and also turns into tyranny I
think the two are supposed to go in an
arm and arm and there is attention and
the tension will always exist but I
think that that tension is what animates
life right it states these moments
between faith and reason that you we
spend most of our life making decisions
based on faith in a weird way then and I
kind of predicted this I think I said it
on the show about four months ago I
sense that America might start becoming
more religious but I don't but I don't
know that that will be I don't mean in
the good sense that I think you as
possible today what I what I fear more
so is that because reason has been so
destroyed in the public discourse
because there's so few of us trying to
act to some intellectual honesty that
the secular world won't be able to hold
up its end of the bargain and that
people then will just go to religion for
the wrong reasons and I don't mind that
in this rod sense of that religion is
always wrong or you know even though
women in the tribal sense yeah I'll just
turn into a tribal place of gathering as
opposed to it because you'll have
differences basically yeah I think that
there's I think there's some truth
that I think that in the 19th century
there was an effort by reason to
basically destroy religion I think it
largely succeeded in Europe I think it
took until the 20th century to really
succeed in large measure in the United
States take the heart out of religion
and then I think reason 8 itself I think
the people felt unfulfilled in this
regime of supposed reason in ration Elia
and I think that I think a lot of people
looked at reason itself and they said
well where are you getting the basis for
the idea that there's that our minds
reflect the universe where you're
getting the idea that we even have an
identity right like where does this this
I come from right the day cut the
Cartesian notion that I I think
therefore I am
who's this I that you're talking about
because there is no such thing as
identity right by the time you're you
know your cells aren't replacing
themselves at a rapid rate and you're
changing every day like by the end of
this conversation you will have a
different brain structure then you did
the beginning of this conversation right
and that's not just ten o'clock at the
bottle spoiler alert
it's it's because you know our brains
actually change as time goes on are you
the same person what makes you the same
person science starts asking all these
hard questions and it ends up destroying
a lot of the fundamental premises upon
which science itself is based and so
people just revert back to no I Know Who
I am I am this guy and I'm this guy
who's friends with that guy and if you
don't like that
the two of us just gonna f you off right
I think there is that that aspect of
humankind I don't think that we're
capable of existing in this world where
we can live with the cognitive
dissonance of we may not exist as
individuals but we can have an
individualistic morality we may not
exist in a world that where reason
matters but we can have a rational
conversation I'm not sure that that
exists yeah and I think that's very much
sort of where we're at at the moment
which is ironic because it also it's why
on a personal level we're both
succeeding because we're giving some of
that and yet in terms of a society it's
it's a kind of dangerous place all right
so I gonna do some questions on patreon
and on super chests at you you said no
you want no advance notice you want your
notes always it so it's more fun if
you're on the front I do what I do want
to do a couple others that I think we
have some disagreement on so you are
pro-life on pro-choice and I would
describe myself at this point
I'm progressing Lea pro-choice I think
that too much points I believe that the
first on the most libertarian side of it
I believe that the government shouldn't
be able to tell a woman or a man to meet
with what they want to do with their
body now I understand also
if you believe that there is a life
there then the government is supposed to
protect life so right now I'm gonna
concede you something at the same time
why I'm saying I'm not pro-life the
reason I'm asking like what points am
I'm asking to the press I would say so
from all the from everything I have read
I think that basically until 20 weeks
that 20 weeks they've done enough
studies that they know that that fetus
can feel pain basically and that I would
say at that point I mean this is it's
not actually pro-choice right I mean
you're pro-life beyond 20 weeks I mean
say because people who claim that
pro-choice are generally pro-choice all
the way to plaintiff but I've had people
on the show who have told me that
literally till the week before a nine
month term their approach to party
platform yeah is it quite in the
Democrats in point birth is in the
Democratic platform very radical so
that's not that's true radicalism like
that to me look if a normal pregnancy
happens at six months for whatever you
know a woman gets in a car crashing yeah
whatever and then there's a and there's
a pregnancy a six-month-old baby most of
the time lives you know but so I would
argue that basically for the first
twenty weeks that it's a shitty thing
it's an unfortunate horrible thing that
no one wants to do what I would say that
the woman should be allowed to choose
what to do with her body so I ask you
I'm asking you why on that why is it a
bad thing why it's a terrible terrible
thing you said up to that because I do
believe that look I can't tell you no
one can tell you where the genesis of
life begins so I do believe it is a life
some of this is just a little bit of
belief oh no no that's no that's fine
yeah so but you are so you're
acknowledging that it's at least a
potential life yes and without question
but you think that the woman's right for
any reason or for some reason to do it
well this is where I wouldn't want the
government moralizing people and I
wouldn't want the government telling
people what to do so I so to try it in
the best way that I can be
intellectually consistent I would say
that for any reason up until 20 weeks
where science has proven the fetus can
feel pain that I think you should be
allowed to have an abortion after that
and here's where I think the real
argument is is well alright if the
government is now going to come in and
say you can't have an abortion does the
government now owe you anything which I
also think is a very
position because I don't want the
government having to give you things I
can't care about duty not to kill you
right yeah I mean I assume we're green
so if we agree on this if I don't have a
duty if I ever do not to kill you that
doesn't mean I also ever do to support
you we have a husband to do that it's
patreon that does that but if the
government tells you okay so I get that
point but he doesn't really know right
but but if the government says you
cannot do this and says I can't kill my
child but it's not my jobs it's not the
government's job to support me and
supporting my child right but if you
were trying to kill your child I think
the government has a right to come in
and take away my yeah
right and that's what the pro-life
position would be is that if you're
trying to kill your child the government
has a right to come in protect the child
okay so so you you think basically my
position here is I don't think it's
perfectly luck I mean I think that you
have to set these I think the the beyond
20 weeks thing you're gonna have to do
better as far as your rationale for not
being pro-life like formally pro-life as
in the government should restrict that
squarely on the on the libertarian part
of it okay so the libertarian part of
this is that libertarians believe that
life is worthy of protection this is
like the one thing government is
supposed to do right it's pretty
supposed to stop me from killing you hmm
okay so it's either life or it's not a
life you just suggested that life beyond
six months is basically is a life not
basically is a life 20 week right 28
right to 20 weeks beyond 20 weeks it is
a life sin and I'm not even arguing that
before 20 weeks it's not a life I'm
doing arguing that but you're you're
arguing that it's a fully-fledged life
in the same way that you are I are a
fully-fledged life yeah okay well if
that's the case then the government
obviously has a role in restricting I
mean at that point there's literally no
difference except the location and the
location five inches this way or five
inches this way it does not seem to make
much of a difference and the government
overreach part of this the government
just telling you what to do with your
body no the government's not telling me
I mean the government may be telling you
what to do with my body but it's also
telling me what to do with my body when
I'm not allowed to stab you right I mean
like it's telling me not to take my arm
in and put a knife in it and stab you
right like basically the bodily
integrity argument ceases to exist once
you're talking about doing harm to
another yeah right that I mean that's
the whole rule that's the whole I'm
allowed to wave my arm in any direction
so long as I don't have your face you
know it's interesting because I know
this argument won't compel you but yeah
but I'll give you something that's based
on feel
antic coat for a moment I know I won't
make it happen
III know two girls that in the last year
that I'm friends with that had abortions
and that it was a horrible choice for
both of them you know one in a committed
relationship and I don't know I don't
know all the specifics of their sex life
but they whatever and one that it was
just a one-night stand and in both cases
it was a gut-wrenching horrible thing
that that they did and but they truly
felt that in their own lives that they
could they either wouldn't be able to
support the child or in one case we had
a lot to do with finances but in the
other case just at an emotional level
and all that stuff and the idea that we
would then force them to do that and
then and then at the same time we're
Republicans don't want to then offer any
help
again I don't love the idea of
government help it just it all just
doesn't surprising so on the the to me
the most dangerous thing here is not the
government restricting it's the the
suggestion that human beings have the
subjective capacity to define as like
that which they wish to preserve that's
a really tough one okay there there is a
whole group of people in America who
defined people arbitrarily as property
for hundreds of years and if you said I
won't the government's can remove your
property from you the libertarian
position the way that you're
articulating it might have been okay
well they define that as property who
are you to tell them that it's not their
property rather than that that black
human being is not the same as a plough
and I'm not accusing you of being
pro-slavery but they buy the but the
argument is is strikingly similar in
that once you say that someone gets to
define a human life based on their own
emotional state that's a really
dangerous place to be
there's got to be some sort of objective
definition of human life that at which
time is protected because and you agree
with that because you agree that it's
past birth right but I'm saying that
it's not past birth I'm saying it's much
earlier than that and as far as the
financial point there you know this is
what adoption is for again the
difficulty that you will have and
bearing a child
no one's ever ready first of all they
have a kid you know when you have kids
you make it like if you're lucky you
make decisions if you're not lucky
there's an accident but then you're
lucky because there's a kid you know
kids are because they're wonderful I
have two of them doesn't mean that
you're gonna be happy with your kid
maybe you'll be unhappy okay because it
I don't know but you can also revisit
this in 10 years that's true but your
level of personal discomfort with having
children has no market it has no impact
morally on the definition of whether
that person is a wife or not so the
difficult the argument has cuts no ice
with me so ok so even if I'll even if I
jump on board that does the does the
government or does society have any role
then in making sure that life is is
protected as a life so the answer the
answer is yes but that the government's
role is not in terms of positive rights
it's more in terms of negative meaning
if you mistreat the child if there's
malnourishment if you're not taking care
of the kid the government will come in
and take the baby away from you and the
government should come in and take the
baby away from you you shouldn't be
allowed to starve your baby right legs
also it's just hard for me to square
that on the libertarian side it's like I
don't want the government doing that I
don't want this kid malnourished or
killed or abused or any of those things
but if you malnourished ok I mean I
assume they are not in favor of the
government leaving a kid in the house
he's gonna die no what I mean is I would
always prefer that's done by a local
charity and of course of course I mean
this is what religious communities are
there for them in my view of this when
it comes to charity my view is you first
go to your family then you go to your
church or community then you go to the
local government then you go to the
stake up and they like you move up the
chain you're in terms of where you seek
aid but the the abortion debate is
really not a particularly complex one
and it's always been bewildered to me
that people want to make it so complex
it's it's it's not bottom line is if
this is a life if this is a thing of
value then your arbitrary decision that
it is inconvenient for you does not
Trump the independent rights of that of
that life no it's really that simple
and that's an any attempt to obfuscate
that you're gonna run into all sorts of
problems that are equally applicable to
adults right as soon as you say that you
know I didn't want to have a kid because
I can't afford the kid how many couples
can afford a kid when the kids one right
right we're not ancient Spartans we're
not gonna take our children and start
throwing them off cliffs right so yeah
the the pro-life position it seems to me
is it's it's pretty clear I don't think
that it's it's a vague argument I don't
think it's a particularly complex
argument I think that people try to make
it more complex because they're looking
for a way to make it more morally
palatable or emotionally palatable for
them to do something they want to do in
the first place and what do you make of
how sort of the the left or at least
Hollywood nobody ever goes for this you
know
as a gut-wrenching decision to have the
child mm-hmm but I always only heard the
stories about the gut-wrenching decision
to terminate a child you never hear the
gut-wrenching said I was really
struggling with should I have an
abortion or not and then I made the
gut-wrenching and ultimately an
ultimately really difficult decision to
have my baby no it always turns out that
it's like you know I was thinking about
getting an abortion then I decided that
was a bad mistake and then I had the
kittens been great right like it's never
got running to choose to have it you oh
you only hear people speaking in the
terms of gut-wrenching and difficult and
all the way the hassle had to go through
to make this decision when they make the
eventual decision that they want to have
an abortion which says to me a lot of
people know deep down that they're doing
something that has moral weight and they
don't want to acknowledge it so instead
they just rewrite the the logic and say
this this thing has no more weight at
all and this is why I was asking at the
very beginning yeah why is it bad that
somebody has an abortion in 19 weeks
right if you if you acknowledge I am it
knows I know if you take the safe legal
and rare position is why I think the
Democratic Party position from the 90s
makes no sense when they say safe legal
and rare the question is why rare you
wouldn't say removal of a polyp safe
legal and rare
mm-hm it's a safe and legal right I mean
it's a polyp if your position is a
baby's not a baby then who cares if you
kill it if your position is the baby's a
baby then you got a whole world of hurt
on your hands morally speaking by saying
it's okay to kill it yeah and and as I
would have said to you when we started
this portion the conversation I mean
this is why I say budging Lee yeah I I
dry
I'll get you over here but really
nothing if not flexible mentally you
know let's just do one more actually in
the mood jump to to the patreon and and
super chat questions death penalty which
I actually don't think we've ever
discussed the two of us so see what you
can do here I am again this is where I
go to the libertarian side quick I don't
think that the state has the right to
kill people I'm not even going to make
the argument that they make mistakes
which that's where everyone usually goes
that right that's the easy no people
that we did and then that's the best
argument against the death penalty
really the state definitely has a right
to kill you if you kill another person
so square your small government
libertarian side of ben shapiro with
your conservative side that is i mean
it's the state of the right to jail
people yeah we've got a long case they
can deprive you of liberty so I can't
take a private of life depending on the
nature of the crime there is something
there is a difference the wire is simply
a difference that ending a life is
different than
I agree but that's why I'm saying
depending on the nature of the I'm not
suggesting the state has the right to
remove your life from you for stealing a
shoelace I am saying that if you're
Hitler the state definitely has a right
to take you out and and shoot you is
that a sort of functionality of the
government like that so there is a
functional argument the functional
argument is that if you have a bunch of
people who commit murder and then are
running around then you end up in tribal
warfare very quickly right the family
you end up basically with with Godfather
one right you have its Raju as we get it
such but you do end up with basically
two battling street gangs that you
killed Sonny okay so now I'm gonna kill
your son and you know we both lost sons
and now it can make peace but don't
worry the fees will not last for long
and that the tribal societies rest on
the notion there's no centralized
authority that is the ultimate arbiter
of power with regard to judicial crimes
the idea there is that you kill a member
of my family okay I'm gonna come kill
whenever you're a family you're gonna
kill them all and that this is how you
end up with this what a true cycle of
violence where people just keep going
back and forth killing members of each
other's family so the state says instead
of doing that how about the guy commits
murder this is not just a crime against
your family it's a crime against the
people at large because you've destroyed
a member of the community and so we have
the collective capacity to put that
member of the community to death in the
same way that we have the capacity to
put that member of the community in jail
I think that if you're gonna make the
completely anarchist argument that
nobody should ever be jailed by the
state that's it so I'm not making that
right but once you make the argument
that the state has the capacity to do
justice mmm-hmm then removing the death
penalty on the grounds that the state
doesn't have that that's where you draw
the line for the state it's I'm not sure
why that line should exist other than
sort of gut-level feeling like you don't
want the state killing people and that's
more of a gut thing than then a logic
thing I would say yeah I mean to me it's
just giving the government that much
power but I understand your argument
you're saying or look if you're giving
them the power already to jail you for
life you've already ceded the power
argument so again I find my position on
both of these I know is not the best
timing is the death penalty is it's just
applied crappily right I mean that's
that's the best argument against the
death penalty if you there are systems
where where death penalty is applied
much in much quicker fashion you know
that's 16 years on death row right and a
system of Appeals and it's not
arbitrarily applied by juries and all
this
well they say it costs more to put
someone death and it does to keep them
in jail for life yeah that I'd heard
that as well I'm one of those stats
where I buy it like I'm always it's
really like they're getting a lot of
good food like did it make the food
crappy or if they're there for 35 years
but if you know they're 16 we just get
them like the steak every night like I
just don't know how that stat works but
yeah I want to look into it all right
we're gonna check on that all right I
actually do want to do one more with you
because sorry I've mentioned to you
earlier so I was after this turning
point USA thing that we both did and by
the way on that even that to me showed
the change that's happening right now
I wasn't there the night you spoke I
spoke I think the next night but I saw
the video of you walking out there and
it was like it was like a rock star
performance pretty cool yeah but were
going bananas and then when I was there
the next day I talked about being you
know gay married I talked about being
pro-choice I talked about all the
different things I had with this group
of people and I got a standing ovation
for yeah like so this idea that these
are somehow the intolerant people is is
so lost it's so over and done that I
just think that's worth mentioning but
when I was driving across across the
state and I happened to turn on the
Glenn Beck show and yeah you were guest
hosting you said something about taxes
that I thought was really interesting
you were talking about the tax cuts
which I just come through I think the
day the day before and you said alright
well that that that's easy okay fine I'm
with Trump on that but what this really
about what this is really about is
spending and this is the part that no
one talks about and I thought you framed
it really interesting Lee because
basically now they're gonna go in and
they're gonna do some infrastructure
stuff or whatever it is but that in
effect will never actually get the
spending down because you can say tax
cut tax cut tax cut and you can actually
do it and that's good people get more
money in their pocket okay great
but in effect if you just keep spent
it's a spending issue not a not a not a
cutting yeah not a taxing issue right
that's exactly right I mean the fact is
that it is always politically convenient
to do a tax cut for Republicans it is
never politically convenient to actually
do the stuff that has to be done right
until it gets to the point like Germany
where you just have to make austerity
cuts but the the idea that any of these
political parties have the brass to
actually come out and say listen we're
gonna have to restructure Social
Security sorry about this if you're
already on Social Security you'll get
your benefits but if you're under the
age of 50 it's up to you now we're gonna
privatize this stuff you can put an
account
you can you can take it you can put in
the stock market you can save it but
you're not getting in you're not getting
out what you put in and you're not
you're certainly not getting a multiple
right you're we're not gonna let you do
this routine where you put in 80 bucks
like my grandmother a month all right I
take out 3,000 a month like money and
money didn't have babies like it just
magically multiplied that way if nobody
does that then you and I we're not gonna
see our Social Security right that
money's gone and the same thing is true
of Medicaid and Medicare sixty six
percent of the budget this is seventy
percent of the budget is in these social
programs and so when people talk about
the defense budgets too high I agree in
many ways the defense budget may be too
high right me we should go through and
we should line-item audit it but to
suggest that we're going bankrupt
because of the war in Afghanistan or
Iraq is just completely ignorant I mean
the amount of money that we're spending
on entitlements is it Dwarfs that so I'm
Kay so I heard you actually made that
point when I was listening to you if
someone was to come across and just say
let's just do a ten percent
across-the-board military cut like let's
just do that figure out ways to be more
efficient we're not gonna hamper you
know they'll that I know certain people
will say well now you're handicapping
the military about but just really like
10 percent we know you guys have an
insane amount of money let's figure out
ways to be more efficient there's even
that this is there a flag for you on
something like maybe the only thing
that's a flag for me is that I don't
know enough about the military budgeting
to know what the proper percentage would
be so it's it's hard for me to tell
you're not against the cut - no I'm not
against looking at all of the the waste
and the and whether the bidding is
competitive or whether each operating
system is is absolutely necessary to
national defense I just think that when
it comes to the proper functions of
government defense is one of them and I
don't think that Social Security
Medicaid and Medicare are proper
functions of federal government yeah on
the military side there was the problem
that we just never do that right like we
never actually check well right I mean
we did actually do that with
sequestration right sequestration
actually put a hard cap on military
spending we actually did that was the
deal that the the Boehner Congress made
with Obama was that we're gonna have
across-the-board cuts but those cuts
were going to be 50% defense in 50%
everything else the problem is why are
you doing 50% defense and 50% everything
else it should be what the percentage is
if you're gonna do that right it should
be like 80% everything else and 20%
defense but in any case the that's why
when people say you know you're are you
for small government or big government
what I really say is I'm for the proper
function of government being properly
funded and for the defunding of all non
proper phone
of government which would inherently
make it a lot smaller yeah so what are
some things that you would cut costs on
Oh everything I mean I would I would
keep that would keep the military I
would I'd get rid of the Department of
Education I'd get rid of the National
Park Service I would get rid of the EPA
I would get rid of all of these I would
get rid of virtually everything in the
in the executive branch of the federal
government and then I'd have Congress
actually legislate like if you want all
these things beyond national park let
Congress legislate for the National Park
and then we can hire five people they
take care of that national park and
everything will be better you know
instead we have all of these plethora of
multiplying agencies that are almost
completely useless and it really is just
a way for Congress to abdicate its duty
Congress doesn't legislate on anything
anywhere they passed a thousand-page
bills no one's ever read then the
regulator's rewrite everything and such
a bunch of regulators you've never heard
of who are in thrall to lobbyists who
are writing all the regulations that
actually govern how we live which is
insane and it all ties back into where
we started with this about how everyone
flips on everything because of the team
thing yeah so it's like I had so little
sympathy two weeks ago for the Democrats
that were screaming you Republicans
never no one read the tax bill meanwhile
five years ago all the Republicans
screaming nobody read Obamacare and they
were mocked so it's like you're all
doing it we all see it and it's partly
why I think that the short attention
span we have is so dangerous that the
social media part of this is so
dangerous because it's making us
actually forget what they're doing up
just a couple years ago where we all
then are saying the reverse of totally
because we've evolved but because we're
devolve yeah yeah I mean this is when
people say you know if you can have one
constitutional amendment what would it
be the one that I always say is I would
have a constitutional amendment that no
bill passed through Congress can be on
more than one topic or longer than ten
pages right that everything should be
this long yeah let's let's write it
let's vote on the stuff in bite-size
chunks because that way we can actually
have time to digest it and look at it
these omnibus packages never work out
well for the American people yeah I mean
it's just they just stuff in all the you
know defense things have things you know
it's just it's crazy it's bananas on
that note we're gonna take a one-minute
break you want some booze during the
break sure people would like to see
Shapiro get drunk maybe we can get a
pair of drunk people give us 60 seconds
we're taking questions on patreon which
you guys have already submitted a whole
bunch and we're going to be doing the
Super chat thing so jump
in there right now give us 60 seconds
now we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back with mr. fax over
feelings bench Bureau we have roughly
400,000 questions okay do you do you
have the Stanley tock let's find out
all right patreon first any good banning
stories from when you worked for him
well let's see the ones that'll get me
sued or the ones that won't get me sued
I have to the problem is that my entire
relationship with Steve ban and span
from when I was working at Breitbart
originally he I joined Breitbart two
weeks before Andrew died and then bannin
really became instrumental there about
two weeks after Andrew died and then the
last time I talked to Bandhan was the
weekend before I quit which was in March
2016 so I am weary he's a little just
fellow and I'm weary of telling I let's
put this way I do have magnificent
Bannen stories and then they are grand
and once the camera goes off I will tell
you I'll repeat them at another time
this is good any basically the question
is any thoughts on cryptocurrency I
really yeah I'm talking about I mean so
what I've said on cryptocurrency is that
I really like the idea of cryptocurrency
I don't like the idea of the government
being in control of inflation of the
monetary supply and George Gilder has an
excellent book in which he basically
recommends blockchains and
cryptocurrency as sort of the wave of
the future I've never understood it as
an investment as much as a hedge against
government failures so in the same way
that I treat gold or real estate as sort
of a hedge against government inflation
it's a hard asset yeah that's that sort
of how I see it right now it seems like
more of a marketing opportunity that
anything else I could've bought now and
then this happens to be the
cryptocurrency everyone picks up then
you do great right but you know I'm not
expert enough with the market to know
whether it's peaked at 19,000 or whether
it's peaked at 13,000 or whether it's
gonna take another hit when another
cryptocurrency Rises it has better
security system than Bitcoin I've got a
little bit and it's just like you watch
it go up and down and you just kind of
see what happens
alright I'm doing these in literally in
literally no order so we'll do some
super chats here if it's the government
job to stop the individual from aborting
a child doesn't the government have the
right to levy increased taxation to
support lower-cost child adoption and
orphanage protection services so this is
a little
about what I asked you is what role then
does the government have if the
government is going so the government so
my view is that the government has a lot
of negative police power but not a lot
of positive power meaning that to to
levied so yes the government has the
power to levy taxes to remove a child
from the home because the government has
the police power so that's a police
power does the government have the
capacity to force to to raise lots of
money to put this kid in a plush mansion
no I think this is where the government
is best off working with private
adoption agencies to ensure that parents
who are capable of taking the child in
do so and that's one of the major
problems that we have in the country
that nobody talks about ever is the this
vast disconnect between the adoption
system the adoptive parents and the kids
is just insane there are literally
millions of parents or seeking kids and
can't get them in large part because the
government stands between parents and
kids in many cases it's more of a wall
than a window unfortunately all right
super chato that it's my man raka he
asked a couple things here but I think
the the most interesting one the Praeger
lawsuit that's happening right now
it's obviously directly related to what
you do to what I do it's very personal
for us we both know Denis where do you
stand on this again this is where I my
libertarian side right not happy about
this and yet I do think there's a
counter argument I think you and I are
on the same page so I have a libertarian
side that says YouTube has its contract
there are business as long as they're
not violating their own contracts with
their their clients they can do what
they want and on the other side I agree
that YouTube can be extraordinarily
discriminatory and how they do monetize
videos and all of that and that should
be a spur for us to create our own our
own businesses that that basically mimic
that and you know their their ways the
you make money that are not subject to
YouTube their ways that I make money
that are not subject to YouTube and I
think that's good so you know my
libertarian side tends to win out here I
think that the power of the free market
if YouTube forces a bunch of people out
then I think that they're going to be
there they're gonna be cruisin for a
bruisin and I think that's that's true
for a lot of these corporations
everybody talks about Facebook and
Google and all these places rule the
world look at the fortune 500 from 30
years ago and how many of those
companies are still in the fortune 500
the answer is not a lot yeah all right
super chat what are both of you think
about the Trump tax plan specifically
how much disproportionately more rich
pay than the rest of us so it's so funny
when I was listening to like just
anyone talk about it it's like people
say literally the opposite things yes
and it's like get any truth out of this
thing I'm wildly confused by people who
think that you know rich people are
significantly benefiting in places like
California I'm actually paying more tax
under the term tax plan which I support
it I'm paying more tax because they got
rid of the state and local tax deduction
yeah and so that means that we pay
1,000% tax in California and then we
also pay 1,000% tax from the federal
level so I get I'm one of the few people
in America who actually get smacked by
the Trump tax plan yeah well what do you
make for the general argument that the
rich should always pay more I disagreed
this completely I believe in a flat tax
so if you're gonna have either a flat
tax or sales tax those seem to me the
only things that are even morally
arguable the idea that I ought to pay a
higher percentage of my money because
I'm making more money makes no sense to
me at all I've made not a lot of money
I've made a lot of money and guess what
I'm the same person at both times and
this idea that I became somehow morally
bereft when I made lots of money and now
I deserve to have my money confiscated
right the whole point of me working
harder was to make more of that monies
that I can spend it on frivolous things
for my children and by the way me
spending the money on the frivolous
things for my kids keeps people in most
frivolous business in business and it's
also it's also interesting me because if
you take it to the most personal level
like you and I do a very similar thing
as a living right
I suspect you probably have more money
than me I don't deserve your money if
you'd like to give me something really
if you just take it to that person well
they go and people go up and down I mean
this is the other thing people will say
well he's a one-percenter like now I'm a
1% rate guess what three years ago I
wasn't one percenter four years ago I
wasn't ooh one percenter right and there
will be a time I'm sure in the future
when I probably won't be a one-percenter
again and by the way the one percenter
thing I mean when they say that it's you
I think it's something around four
hundred thousand which is nicely there's
a lot of money but you're not when they
say it right it makes it sound like it's
five million dollars a year or something
that you're pulling the levers of power
I mean we're four hundred thousand bucks
or whatever it is not in California in
Texas you in Texas you're a wealthy
wealthy man in California that means
they can afford a two-bedroom apartment
in Studio City
all right super Chad I'm planning on
joining the army and I'm struggling with
the morality of taking part in a war
with such high civilian death rates and
interfering with the country's right to
self-determination thoughts this is a
good question I mean I think that
obviously you're the only person who can
really define kind of
what your morality is on these things I
think those are good things to think
about is what you'll have to do and
whether it's something that you're
willing to do I'm grateful to you that
you're considering it because I didn't
do it and so anybody who does is making
a sacrifice I didn't make so I'm
grateful for that consideration you know
look I think that every war is gonna be
fought differently I think that it
depends on the war depends on whether
you trust the leadership but in the end
there is a fairly solid foreign policy
consensus even if you disagree with
particular wars between right and left
it seems to have been exaggerated in
recent years cuz the war in Iraq but the
truth is that until it was George W Bush
who wanted to fight the Lauren Rock it
was Bill Clinton want to fight the war
in Iraq so it's yeah that I think some
of the gaps here a little bit
exaggerated hey Ben do you have any
thoughts to offer up on the works of
iron Rand and objectivism sure oh yeah
you've talked about this a little bit I
know you said we said we were gonna try
to work a sit-down with your own bro
yeah which I think would be fine so yeah
I know your runs been critical of my of
my terminology of capitalism where I've
said that it's forced altruism because
anytime you say the word
altruism in the presence of an
Objectivist then it's like water on the
other one with less they just start
melting and it's all crazy but what I
mean by forced altruism is the sense
that you know if I don't give you
something that you want then I starve
meaning that there's an externality to
me to me living that I have to generate
for you in order for me to get something
in return so whether use altruism or not
we have the same perspective on on
capitalism I think that on capitalism
there's been very there's very few
expositors of capitalism who I think are
better than Iran as far as her life
philosophy and her relationship
philosophy I think that's pretty garbage
I don't think objectivism applies in
personal relationships now the way that
a lot of objectives get around the idea
that like you're gonna abandon your wife
and children because there's a hot chick
at the bar but because Objectivist they
would say that's not rational
self-interest right it was so that
they'll read they'll redefine the
terminology right they'll say that
you're not making a sacrifice for a wife
and children you've made a decision that
it makes you happier to be with your
wife and children and the rational
person would make that decision that
it's better to be with your wife and
children a lot of 40 year old men
driving Corvettes would disagree all
right so I I really don't think that's
correct well I wonder if they disagree
or they just have a moment of stupidity
I mean maybe but you know it's the
president's married three times each
time to a younger hotter moderate model
so it's you know I
that I have less faith in in human
nature than to believe that the reason I
stick with my wife and kids is because
it always makes me happy there's plenty
of times when I'm with a screaming child
in the middle of the night when what
would best serve my interest is to
thrust the drugging so right alright
well we'll facilitate that conversation
at some point when you guys are both
around all right super chat if both
sides regard quote the other as evil is
it inevitable that we will eventually
destroy each other as the result of our
differences in the concept of morality
I'll just add one little pieces that I
sort of see something like this
happening but a whole bunch of us good
decent people which I actually think is
most of us they're not gonna keep trying
to hold some sort of sane middle thing
but they inevitably of the two sides
that want to destroy each other that
believe the other side is evil is sort
of something that we can't ultimately
guard against from both I mean I think
this is right the politically driven
this is something where then the
narrative of politics is strongest and
most most useful when it is these stark
terms when you talk about good and evil
this is what motivates people right
every war speech ever given in any film
is all about how the other guys are
really evil because it's motivating and
that's gonna be true in politics also
when it gets to individuals and this is
why you talk about individuals why I
talk about individuals a lot of that
goes out the window there's a study that
I heard Arthur Brooks talking about
recently on podcast where he was talking
about how in the 1930s there's a Chinese
couple that went around the United
States staying at hotels and they were
never discriminated against they went to
like 250 hotels one of them turndown
service then afterward they called all
250 hotels on the phone and said we're a
Chinese couple we want to stay and 240
them so we won't serve Chinese couples
meaning that when people were actually
confronted with the actual human being
that they were talking to and they
weren't willing to go follow through on
their ideological discrimination and and
their stereotypes about the evil of
Chinese people then they were just
willing to treat you as an individual
and I think that's one of the things
that's been lost with the lack of
community like how many times you
actually talk with a person who you
don't talk with every day in today's
society the answer is not very often
right on social media it's always behind
a twitter handle which means that you
can which is really more for insulting
people or on facebook where you never
see the people but you know this is what
Robert Putnam talks about in terms of
the social fabric dissolving and Bowling
Alone and
we don't have communal places anymore
and that's why the people who you find
who are the friendliest contrary to in
my experience contrary to the public
opinion put forth by Hollywood are
people who are in church groups ready to
go to a church group these people treat
you like gold
right I mean I'm an Orthodox Jew I walk
into a church friendly they're all used
to each other they see each other on a
regular basis they do things for each
other
and maybe that only extends as far as
the in-group but I think that the more
often you're interacting with various
difference in groups the more often
you're going to be willing to you know
count in somebody who disagrees with you
yeah well listen I mean my own personal
experience is and I said in my direct
message from this morning I will give
the exact same speech that I gave at
Turning Point USA in front of all those
conservatives I'll give it to any
progressive group if they'll invite me
yeah but I suspect they will not I mean
Dave and Ben you guys red built me and I
can't thank you enough for that I've
learned too much to express my
appreciation in 200 characters but I
genuinely can't thank you enough all
right not a question but that's it
reminds me of the girl that when I was
at the local store over here the the BEC
picking up bug spray and the girl said
she was a big fan of mine she goes but I
really like ben shapiro there you go
okay hi hi Dave and Ben do you got for a
second do you think more states will
join the u.s. in recognizing Jerusalem
as Israel's capital I'll answer it first
I mean I definitely think I think
there's a lot of reasons that states are
quietly lining up to you right now
yeah I think that's right and I think
that some of the states that want to do
it the most are actually the states that
you think about the least right I think
Saudi Arabia would love to do it but
they can right the fact is that what
Trump did is is smart in a lot of ways
one of the ways it's smart is he just
Rhian tried the Saudi Egyptian Jordanian
Israeli alliance against Iran and he
basically said listen let's get on the
same page here Jerusalem's off the table
you know Israel's not gonna give that up
so deal and Saudi Arabia is fine with it
by the way Saudi Arabia the Mohammed bin
Sultan he's he's going around telling
the Palestinians shot just like just be
quiet
how about be nice for a change and we
can actually move to some sort of real
solution here I think there will be more
states that join up but this goes to a
fundamental disconnect that I think the
left and the right have about American
leadership in the world the left
believes that morality on the world
stage is defined by majority vote
particularly majority of the Europeans
and the
believes that morality is defined by
certain eternal principles that we
believe in for whether religious or
ideological reasons and then we say
America has to do its best to try to
promulgate those principles and people
like Obama will say well we have to lead
from behind because those principles are
really malleable on the face of the
world stage so if the Europeans don't
like us moving our embassy to Jerusalem
that means that we've done something
terribly wrong right this is where they
always talk about what about
international law or what about what the
UN said or what about what the Europeans
rap international international laws
[ __ ] this is it Leon ers has aligned
and I think to Milla 18 is a novelist
and me'll 18 is a really good book about
the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising where he says
international law is that which the good
refused to enforce and the evil refused
to abide by that is good putting aside
even the moral argument and historical
argument of why Jerusalem should be
controlled by the Israelis we're by the
way it's an international City and there
are literally men or ultra-orthodox men
walking next to women in burkas as I saw
not too long ago but even putting all of
that aside and that and that Palestine
as a state never existed and the
Jordanians used to occupy Jerusalem at
the putting back all of that stuff that
the left refuses to acknowledge any of
that just on a per on a purely strategic
point it strikes me as a good move by
Trump because it's like the Palestinians
literally refused to negotiate Bibi
every year walks around going guy I'll
meet you anywhere Abbas anywhere and he
never does so to me it's like all right
well like this is where Trump the good
negotiator Trump I think actually makes
sense I think this is where the fu Trump
comes in I'm not even sure it's about
him being a great negotiator it's just
like I'm gonna say what is what I think
is true here and we're done and this is
this is where you know the good Trump
bad from dichotomy that I that I you
know have been promulgating for a while
comes in when he's good he's really good
I mean this is what he said when I said
listen this is the reality we can futz
around with this but you guys turned
down two separate offers in the last in
the last 10 years to take Jerusalem as
part of your capital and you turn it
down both times ready Cooper Rock
offered it in 2001 to Gaza for our fight
our fights started the Second Intifada
instead a hoot on their offer the
internationalization of the Old City of
Jerusalem which is insane insane and in
in a boss walked away from the table
without even a counteroffer in 2007 but
I don't know exactly what you want from
Israel or from the United States on that
let's see Ben how are you dominating
Twitter do you have a second moderator
or are you actually living within
Twitter as an artificial intelligence
that Stan Paris warns us about I did
want to ask you something about that
like that you have to you play the game
of you know you're saying a lot of smart
stuff on Twitter but you're also you're
pretty damn good troll well yeah yeah
yeah you you've got there those are only
I mean and then I handle my own Twitter
account so on my Facebook account then I
have a couple people who work for me who
will post articles from time to time but
the but on my Twitter account that's
that I enjoy too much to give up so you
know when I'm doing the memory and and
you know when I when I decide to do 2017
in one Jeff and all that that's just
because I get a kick out of whether
that's it's so much fun oh this is a
good one from Supertramp man what is
your opinion on centrism and people who
identify as centrist I thought I saw a
little movement with centrist in the
last year now I'm not sure where I don't
know what it means this is my big
problem I'm not fond of terminology that
I have no clue what it means and
sometimes the centrist just means I'm
too lazy to pick a side mm-hmm so I'm
more than generally like well I don't
know that means I think generally people
mean it to be like socially liberal
fiscally conservative like this right so
they say that if they say that then oh
and then I get clarification usually on
what you mean by socially liberal and
then we can have a conversation about
where you're right and where you're
wrong that's a more specific way to boil
it down what I get the feeling from a
centrist is like moderate or independent
is something somebody says when they'd
really don't want to talk politics or
when they just want to say I don't like
the Democrats I don't like the
Republicans a pox on all of you I'm I'm
better than everybody I just want to say
how handsome you both look love
listening to both of you great way to
start the new year Cheers at the fan
time right we agree there we go
oh this is a good one from super chat
what do you think the country would look
like right now if Hillary had won the
election politically and culturally well
so I think that we'd be about as ribbon
as we are now I don't think that we
would be significantly less ribbon the
the right was not happy with the
prospects of a Hillary Clinton
presidency and Hillary is very
off-putting human being who has a nasty
tendency of being terrible of other
people so I don't think that like he was
saying about Trump is so alienating
there was this lady named Hillary and
she was not and like I think from is
more overtly alienating than
but the difference is the difference
that the media would have treated her
like the Queen basic yes so this is oh
it would have been much more in small
quarters where the the hangar would mean
I think that's true I think that
anything the fact that that's a great
point I think the fact that media have
been so all over Trump all the time has
ratcheted this up to 11 all the time
yeah I think for the right it would be a
constant 11 because I think there would
be sheer panic in a lot of quarters like
are we ever gonna win another election
and this is totally crazy on the other
hand would Hillary be getting a lot of
stuff through notes you have a
Republican Congress and by the way the
Republicans probably gained in the
midterms so is it so I think that on
domestic policy it would be it would be
worse cuz Trump's done some affirmative
good on foreign policy I think it would
be a fair bit worse because Hillary was
committed to the Iran the Iranian policy
of the of the Obama administration which
is one of the worst policies in the
history of the United States Ben do you
think there's a link between IQ and
career success and family stability do
you think there is such a thing as
cognitive elite so I mean the studies
tend to say yeah the studies tend to say
that the data tend to say that you will
probably earn more money if your IQ is
higher up to a point of diminishing
returns actually I think that the the
statistic that I saw was something like
once you get 160 then the income starts
to come down again because you forget
how to talk to humans you're so smart
that you turned into Eric Weinstein and
Eric's like one of the only people with
an IQ above 160 where it's like he's
doing really well for himself or Peter
right like there's are there a few
people who are like geniuses geniuses
who make tons of money and it's usually
in industries where they've never had to
talk to another human right but is it
but overall the answer is yes I mean if
you're smarter you're going to have
advantages as far as making better life
decisions I think that the answer is
also yes but I don't think that it I
think it's a matter of degree rather
than a matter of kind meaning that the
decisions that you have to make in order
to have a mildly successful life in the
United States are not supremely
difficult ones it's why I say you don't
have to get straight A's don't have to
go to Harvard you don't have to do any
of those things to lead a happy life in
the United States all you have to do is
get a job and don't have maybe before
you get married and finish high school
and finishing high school the United
States is not that big a deal
and don't put that thing there without
that thing on it you're fine and you
know get in getting a job like there are
jobs available you may not want to take
the job but there are jobs available so
I don't think everyone's gonna be
equally successful because I don't think
everyone is equally given capacity but
this has been true
human history and that doesn't mean you
get to punish some people for the
benefit of others particularly because
in a capitalist system the benefit of
others benefits you I mean the fact of
the let's say there was a let's say Bill
Gates's the cognitive elite okay fair
enough he's very smart guy cognitively
how many people have job because of Bill
Gates whereas if we had just said to
Bill Gates when he was young you
remember the cognitive elite now we're
gonna chain you to this machine you're
gonna work right next to that other guy
who's not cognitively elite but now
you're both equal how many people would
work for Golden Gates nobody and so the
fact is that it is good that I thought
about this actually before there's a
weird kind of thought question for you
David tell me so would you rather be the
stupidest person in a really smart
society or the smartest person in a
really stupid society I'd rather be the
stupidest person in a smart society I
think that I could get something out of
it I mean I think that's it I think
that's the moral answer and I think it's
also the more effective answer because
the truth is that if you're the smartest
person in 11th century Britain you're
still gonna die at age 35 dysentery okay
but if you're if you're the stupidest
person alive today in the United States
you're gonna live to 70 and you're gonna
have a TV in the microwave in a car so
so the this is the this is the general
point about cognitive elites what makes
industry go what makes capitalism happen
what makes you have a job and a better
life and all the cool stuff that you
have not what allows you to watch this
show on a magic connection that goes up
to space and back down here I have no
freaking clue right I don't know I don't
know that works either it's because
they're cognitively or smarter than I am
I put that together yeah we kind of hit
on this one this is patreon hi Ben as a
libertarian who's socially conservative
I'm curious if you think conservatives
will ever actually stop the growth of
government scope spending and debt
virtually all conservative politicians
campaign on shrinking government but
virtually all of them are satisfied with
the power and spending once in office so
we did hit on this is there anything
that I mean the only thing I would add
is I think that you know it's the the
calculation for getting elected and
staying elected or two different
calculations getting elected you can
make a lot of promises staying elected
you actually have to bring home the
bacon your district in many cases and
the only way that there's gonna happen I
know people have suggested a convention
of states I think that might be a good
idea and have an actual constitutional
convention where we legitimately
restricts the powers of the federal
government again
but it'll take some politicians of
courage who aren't afraid to only serve
one term because serving two terms after
saying I'm gonna cut your social
security is not always the easiest thing
yeah you think the founders would all be
rolling on their graves knowing how many
lifetime politicians we have and even
you know from from McCain too you know
it's all over the map so say McCain and
I'll also say Bernie and a guy like
Bernie who actually never really
accomplished anything in 30 years beat
Orrin Hatch in the Senate for 41 years
right yes retired they had all hate this
right I mean they would absolutely I
mean they all had other jobs I mean John
Adams was a lawyer then George
Washington was a general and then Thomas
Jefferson was a thinker and a farmer I
mean they all had they all had other
jobs that doesn't mean they didn't love
politics but what they really would be
appalled by is the size of government I
mean even the Federalists would have
looked at this thing on what in the
world is this remember they rebelled
over tax rates that were more than the
California state tax right probably
right and it wasn't the idea that was
pretty close to the no taxation without
representation thing so they were really
and that's that's right super check what
are both of your predictions for the
upcoming midterm elections I mean it's
hard to look at the data not conclude
Republicans get relaxed right now the
the the Republicans in and off you in
repent and off your elections the party
in power in the White House typically
loses anywhere from 23 to 25 seats right
now that Republicans have a 23 seat
majority which means that if they lose
the average number of seats they
probably lose the majority in the house
right now it doesn't look like they're
going to lose an average number of seats
the the enthusiasm on the left is
extraordinarily high the enthusiasm on
the right for showing up is is mediocre
at best
and president Trump's personal toxicity
is not helping the situation if he would
just shut up then I think that
Republicans would have a better shot of
holding the house but I think that the
fact that he's in the headlines every
day for saying whatever a crazy thing he
said today is not helpful to him but
there's a problem for me because
actually like a lot of things he's doing
now like now I have a stake in him in
him doing well right but there a problem
with that argument because he did what
no one said he could do so then to say
well now do it the right way no one
would ever do it I did what none of you
said I could but as I just said there's
a difference between getting elected and
staying elected and not only that Trump
did not win that election Hillary
Clinton lost that election okay Trump
Trump won but nobody in Trump camp from
thought they were gonna win I mean that
day they
like yeah I mean I know here in the
camps there yeah that's right and that's
not a rip on Trump from did do something
incredible but that is an accomplishment
not a strategy right and there was no
strategy to pretend there was any
strategy to the from campaign at all
other than we're gonna actually visit
some swing states which was strategic
Hillary Clinton was the worst candidate
in the history of the United States by
an enormous margin how do we know
because she lost to Donald Rock right we
had an approval rating of 36 percent at
the time of the election you can't do
that and hope to sustain I mean at least
maybe you can hope that the Democrats
are stupid enough to run Kamala Harris
or something but it's if they if they
run Joe Biden I think he's got a problem
in 2020 which pains me because I think
that right now Trump is doing a lot of
things that I like personally even as I
just like the tearing apart of the
social fabric good god I mean if it's
Joe Biden at that age and everything
else what a sad state of affairs it
probably will be I mean I think it'll be
Biden versus Trump and the baby boomers
will never leave and then they'll be
artificially propped up on and will move
their best at the end of the election
and they'll be that was pretty good
there was a good one here I just lost it
oh how did we not touch on universities
at all for the first hour but what would
you do to Unruh form the university how
would you fit so the first thing you
have to do is you have to go to the alum
and you have to say listen and your
money is going for a bunch of crap and
then you have to have the alum go and
pressure the universities on the second
if you're hiring you shouldn't hire
based on just the credentialing of what
University somebody wants you the truth
is the simplest way to kill the
university system would be to reverse
the Supreme Court decision that prevents
employers from using IQ tests that's
basically what university systems are
there just filtration systems for
various people of IQ so that's how you
know that someone who went to CSUN is
probably not of the same IQ level as
somebody went to Harvard not a rip on
CSUN but that's just the way it works
right different SAT scores all the SAT
is a basic IQ test so what if we didn't
have that what if we just said okay you
know what from now on we're gonna give a
basic IQ test and you'll do an
apprenticeship you don't have to do any
of this lesbian dance Theory nonsense
and in college you know that we first of
all cut out an enormous amount of time
and energy and money from the system and
then if you actually want to go to
college and study something that
requires higher learning like you know
my wife's a doctor
as I've mentioned 1000 times each
episode you know if she you know goes to
medical school she requires training if
I am a lawyer I basically require six
months in a law firm before I'm you know
qualified to do that kind of work
I don't need three years of law school
and four years of undergrad for that
well that's also why this is the free
college for everyone it's like actually
there's a lot of good jobs you can have
where you make good money that you don't
need to and you can learn a trade and it
may not be the sexiest thing in the
world but you can live or actually
really good life and what I'm saying the
vast majority of trades shouldn't
require like right of like white-collar
jobs should not require going to college
right anything that you can get with a
Poli Sci degree is something you could
have gotten without a Poli Sci degree I
know I have a Poli Sci degree let's see
then what are your thoughts on the
danger of UN Agenda twenty one twenty
thirty do you know what that is so I
seem to recall that it had some poses to
our country and individual rights yeah
you know again I'm not so agenda21 was
something a lot of people were talking
about as a three or four years ago where
they're talking about national regime of
international law in which the United
States surrenders some of its
sovereignty to international
institutions any deal under which the
United States would surrender any of its
sovereignty to international
institutions is problematic to me but
you know us giving real authority to the
UN is I don't think going to happen
considering that we fund them ya know
there's a better shot now that Trump
knocks the place over and builds a
parking lot which I would be very much
in fact I mean the fact that we're
cutting their funding already is
spectacular and I want to see like I'm
not in favor of eminent domain being
used for private purposes but if Trump
bulldoze is the UN and builds a Trump
Tower on it I will make an exception
that's a pretty prime real if they right
there yeah sees it and I mean it that's
a self enrichment deal I'd be willing to
I'd be willing to countenance as long as
it involves knocking down the UN yeah
all right I'm with you on that hey Ben
if the government got out of marriage
how would that affect divorce child
custody etc and his marriage have to be
a religious institution are there any
negative effects of being it of it being
an institution of love
so the okay so there's a really separate
con jobs one isn't one it sort of II do
the first part so the first part is that
marriage should be governed by contract
law meaning that in the Senate I have a
contract of my wife it's called the
ketubah right and that ketubah means
that it states in there how much I owe
her upon divorce I lose ten million
dollars I know that is in the ketubah
so this is this is this is very this is
a good story so so in the in the Jewish
community when you write the kasuba in
the
to buy it says like if you give a woman
a divorce then you have to pay her
basically liquidated damages and so very
often you'll get like negotiations
between the wife's family and the groom
as to what that number is going to be so
my father-in-law comes in one day and
he's like what number do you want in the
ketubah I don't care I'm not getting
divorce I don't care and and he says
well what would you want for his I don't
care put put a hundred million dollars I
don't care it's not gonna make any
difference to me he goes he goes well my
daughter's not worth 100 million dollars
10 million is the thickest Eva and he
was very happy and it's a buddy but in
any case it's a contractual relationship
it's governed by contract law under
private religious courts in the Jewish
community
yeah and that works just fine it's work
just fine for several thousand years at
this point so the idea that the
contracts cannot be had between you and
your husband or between me and my wife
like just because I wouldn't have
same-sex marriages take place at my
synagogue doesn't mean that you guys
can't have a contract between yourselves
like I don't care that's the contracts a
contract enjoy by the way I wouldn't
force your synagogue to marry right
exactly I mean this is the beauty of
living in a free country as I say I can
think that you know what you're doing is
sinful and you can not care like this is
the this is the beauty of it like who
cares I'm sure that you don't like
things I do whatever like that's the
truth it's like obviously we like each
other we're friends but I generally in
the some recess of your mind you think
I'm like an evil sinner or something
like I know I knew when we first off I
don't get that feeling but I genuinely
don't care well like I'm living my life
you're a living your life but I wasn't a
great card this is the part that I've
always been puzzled buys all the people
who seem to desperately crave my
approval like what like do you know me
well enough you want my approval like my
own children you know barely earned my
approval so that could be your first
stand up [ __ ] oh this is good Ben my
girlfriend is a big Milo fan who hates
you how do I fix there first of all have
her watch a tape from Joe Rogan okay
then that the you don't have to have her
watch the him to petting defending
lasting people tape but um I mean what I
would say about Milo's shtick is that
Milo is somebody who is very much driven
by a desperate need for attention I've
been making very clear for years that I
think this leads him down some pretty
dark roads into associations with some
people who I think are very bad for
conservatism I don't think he has a
thoroughgoing worldview other than just
to be a
roll and gain attention and it doesn't
you know I'm not surprised a lot of Milo
fans are not fans of mine because I've
made very clear that I have an
affirmative worldview that I stand up
for whereas I think that Milo can
basically be classified as anti left
rather than as conservative per se like
if you ask Milo what would you do in
government would all be stuff those anti
left I think but yeah I don't think he
thinks about any of that stuff anyway I
don't think that Milo is is a big reader
I don't think Milo is somebody who
spends a lot of time with ideas now
that's not ripping out his intellect I
think Milo seems to be a smart guy but
again he embraced some really terrible
awful people who did some pretty
terrible awful things in the last few
years to make his name and that's
something that I have a deep deep and
abiding disgust with yeah so I'll throw
in a bonus one for me here on that
because I wanted to get to this anyway
where do you draw the line on who you
can interact with or talk to so for
example I've done Alex Jones Show and my
feeling and I got a lot of [ __ ] for it
but people my feeling was well if I it's
live yeah they're not editing me and if
I can talk about the things that I care
about well I might just get some of
those people to come here and start
hearing new ideas and all that so that's
my general policy sometimes I sit you
know I've had other controversial people
like Stefan Molyneux and and a slew of
other people probably on both sides that
people don't want me to talk to you do
you have a general rule for who yes I
mean so I mean the truth is on my
podcast I'm my podcast I don't you
guests so it's it's me monologuing for
45 minutes take it or leave it you know
it's as far as guesting on other
people's programs my general tendency is
that if I feel like the conversation is
going to be productive and it's not me
elevating somebody who I believe to be
morally deficient in a serious way yeah
then that's the latter that's the hard
that that's not because I mean there are
people who you wouldn't have on because
you would feel like you're elevating
them to a certain point you know I I
have the same issue but my my you know
kind of white list may be a little bit
broader
just because you know my ideology is a
little bit more well defined in some
ways Ben would you care to have a
discussion on how to automate the US
Congress Congress I think you're into
them and definitely I'm definitely
actually this is one that I think we
should definitely do is we should just
abolish Washington DC and everybody
should vote for their home district I
don't know why everybody has to be we
have conference calls right we have
Skype I don't know
we have to have all these people living
3,000 miles away stopping they're
stopping their assistance yeah and going
to [ __ ] houses isn't it weird that
something like seven of the nine richest
counties in the United States are all
within that 20 mile radius are no
weirder that it works I couldn't quite
put it together help me with some logic
there let's see
super Chad I'm noticing at Cornell that
conservatives are afraid to share their
opinions in class how much of this
transcends to the workforce what can we
do that that's yeah this is a big tough
one is the workforce particularly busy
because I get this question a lot like I
want to speak out and in it at work but
I'm afraid of the blowback and the
answer is I can't
give you a guidance on that because it
depends on the value of your job I mean
I've told people in Hollywood to shut up
and not lose their job because I don't
think that you should give people the
hammer to beat you with basically does
Mark Hamill drive you crazy on Twitter
if he's a lefty lefty lefty I like I
mean it's on I'm like come on man leave
Luke alone like I'm already pissed at
Luke cause of the movie yeah exactly but
now it's like it's doubly you know I
mean this entire year has been so
bizarre I mean I was sexually harassed
by Rosie O'Donnell right like things are
weird dude so like Mark Hamill was not
high on my list I owe the record I've
broken bread with both you and Rosie and
I have you really want that to happen
but have you really broken bread with
Rosie O'Donnell how'd that go you know
it's actually a pretty great story right
before I was you know I was doing my
thing on Sirius XM but you know it's
much smaller than I guess than I am now
in that sense and I tweeted at her and I
had heard her once say that on the view
she ate wings at this place Blondie's on
the Upper West and I tweeted a picture
of a wing in my mouth and I said Rosie
I'm at Blondie's if you want to get
dinner and she showed up five minutes
later and we spent a couple hours who's
actually was actually great I really
okay you know she's changed a lot also
yeah I don't know when she lost her mind
that I mean like that's now that was a
very weird interaction yeah I had some
strange things happen to you it's this
year man it says we entered a portal but
that was not the right portal like the
as I've been saying for a while I think
that we're now living in the alternate
timeline where Biff actually traveled
back tonight 55 with the sports book and
and changed everything and marty was
unable to prevent it yeah man there we
are on the on the workforce College part
of it I think I've heard you say on the
college part that if it's the classes
that you're majoring in you should shut
up right no it was what I've said is
that you have to gauge my professors
some professors are willing to hear
debate so one of the people who wrote a
law school recommendation for me or a
job recommendation form is Lani Guinier
Lani Guinier is as far left as it's
possible to be she was I think nominated
for Under Secretary of Labor under
Clinton and was refused by a Democratic
Senate cuz she's kind of a socialist Wow
and she and she and I got along famously
we would have debates in class she loved
it I loved it it was great and she ended
up writing a letter of rec for my job
stuff and then there are other
professors where it's like you don't
cross this professor because the
professor is a jerk so button it up um
and so I think you really do have to
gauge it on a case-by-case basis in the
workplace we are entering a really scary
place now particularly social media
where the outrage machine is so strong
that they will basically destroy your
career for anything and it keeps me up
at night I'm sure it keeps you up at
night there's this constant feeling of
being on edge because if at any time the
media sides to crank up the social
outrage machine for no reason at all
right it can be for nothing then is
there anything that you can do about it
right you can sort of hold on for dear
life I mean that's why I want to be my
own boss you know I've had offers this
past year did for a lot more money to do
all sorts of different things but like
I'm my own boss the chances that I fire
myself for are pretty slim here we go
what issues do you think Justice score
such will have the biggest impact on
well I mean right now the court has
split four for one right cuz Anthony
Kennedy is a crazy person so so Justice
Kennedy it depends whether it has
Metamucil that morning how he rules as
far as where he should have the most
impact he is I think administrative law
is an area where he can have a lot of
impact so he is not for something called
Chevron deference Chevron deference is
the idea that administrative courts are
unreviewable by the court except in
cases of clear error and that he is
against which I agree with I don't think
that you can have these kind of kangaroo
administrative courts set up by
regulation and then you can't appeal
that to an actual court in the judicial
system like I don't think the executive
system should be the judicial system so
that's one area that not a lot of people
will talk about also in religious
freedom areas I think that he should be
quite good that'll be good
net neutrality postmortem I mean we're
all dead right
we're all dead the internet is slow
nobody's watching this like it's all
over it's all over we're dead what do
you make of the hysteria around that I
tried to dip this one out because I was
just
like no matter what I say on this it's
just gonna be endless hate frankly I was
shocked by the level of interest in it
and like that that's what I was shocked
by is I gave like a little commentary
about why I was again why I was against
net neutrality and it had like six
million views on Facebook and I was
thinking to myself like really yeah all
I said is that I think that there should
be free and open competition among ISPs
but yeah I see the arguments for both
sides I mean the argument for one side
is that the ISPs are already operating
in the basis of oligarchy and therefore
Oleg Archy and therefore you should you
know restrict their capacity to to
discriminate on the basis of content I
understand I also don't necessarily know
that Riaan training oligarchy through
regulation is the best possible solution
so I'm against that neutrality because I
think that we should remove all these
regulations in the same way that you
know we we are kind of looking for
regulatory solutions to regulatory
problems and I just think we should wipe
away regulations generally so it's
really the same argument that you were
making sort of on the Praeger lawsuit
before yeah exactly
that basically competition is the thing
that will save us not just imagine your
imaginary regular right and I also I
also think that you know when people
were tweeting out crazy stuff like every
Google search is gonna go to $1.99 how
stupid are you people like do you think
that AltaVista wouldn't then immediately
become the biggest engine on planet
earth for like every go around it
wouldn't matter that I wouldn't matter
right amigos back baby back I'm asking
and I'd take all my money and put in Ask
Jeeves and Bitcoin well let's do this
because we didn't do anything on
healthcare hi Ben hi Dave I'm a huge fan
of you both I have a question for Ben
how do I convince my Australian
boyfriend that universal health care is
horrible he likes you but won't waver on
health care you you and Genk my old boss
yeah exactly huge fan of really got into
this yeah we debated this so so the
Australian healthcare system is if I'm
not mistaken more like the Canadian
system than it is like the British
system meaning that you you are people
by supplementary insurance
I believe in Australia's there's a
universal health care system that
provides minimum and then you can buy
supplementary insurance the this is good
for emergency for emergencies like this
universal health care typically is good
for emergencies but it means longer
waits for particular surgeons the
problem of health care is one of supply
not demand it seems like everybody is
trying to look for demand
side solutions to supply-side problems
if you actually want to create more of a
supply of healthcare you actually need
to allow the free market to operate just
like it does in every other area of
Western life and if you wanted to make
sure that everybody was able to get a
bar of soap you can either redistribute
the soap that you have on the shelves or
you can allow people to bid for that
soap and the new soap companies will
come into being they generate more soap
to go for the extra profit the best
example of this in the healthcare sphere
when you have deregulation and not a lot
of insurance companies that are acting
as the middleman is in laser eye surgery
so laser eye surgery used to play twenty
thousand dollars an eye for laser eye
surgery people saw there's a lot of
money in that they got into optometry
and ophthalmology and then it's down to
like three thousand dollars an eye and
is much better that that's because
there's actual price transparency the
biggest problem with the American system
is that there's no price transparency if
you walk in your doctor's office today
and say I want an x-ray yeah they will
not give you a price they don't know the
price they don't know what your
insurance company will say it's all
messed up so there are a lot of think
the reason people like universal health
care is because it's simple in concept
meaning I walk into the doctor and the
doctor either takes care of me or tells
me to come back in eight months with my
hip replacement and he'll take care of
me and I don't have to worry about
anything after that but the simplicity
is sometimes a mask for lesser service
the the best framing that I've seen of
this comes from Dan McLaughlin in
National Review he basically says that
there are a few things that you can have
in health care but not all of them so
you can have university quality or
affordability those three things right
so everyone can have it it can be
affordable or or it can be quality you
have two of those three things he says
but not all three right and so I would
assume that Australia has universality
and affordability but not necessarily
quality in in Switzerland you have
universality and quality but not
necessarily affordability in the United
States you have affordability and
quality but not well
the debatable you may not have any of
them because because there's so many
middlemen but in a free market system
you'd basically have affordability and
quality but not necessarily universality
and then you'd have social institutions
to fill the gap that's been Dave do you
have any comments on the rubbish in
Hanukkah miracle I don't know what that
is
named Shama Bachchan who is a rabbi in
Iowa who was given a 25-year sentence
for a blues bank fraud he was a Orthodox
rabbi who was famous for running the
biggest kosher
Waterhouse in in the United States and
he had been employing illegal immigrants
and then there were some Bank issues
also a couple years ago yeah exactly he
was convicted and he served eight years
so it was a while ago he was given a
25-year sentence and so the argument was
basically by Alan Dershowitz and a lot
of other people the sentence was wildly
disproportionate to the crime that he
committed the crime
but you don't get a 25-year sentence for
bank fraud and that's wildly
disproportionate he was pardoned by the
Trump administration on the last day of
Hanukkah so here are my thoughts on this
the my thoughts are that a crime is a
crime I don't think celebrating a pardon
for a crime is worthy of people meaning
that I think the why they're wild
celebrations in the streets in certain
places I think that you know a subdued a
subdued welcome home would have been
more appropriate I think that when
someone commits a crime and then gets
out of prison that you can be happy
they're out of prison if you think the
sentence was disproportionate but it's
not a good look to have thousands of
people celebrating somebody who just got
out for bank fraud hmm
and so that that's my that's my general
take I think that the Trump
administration did do the right thing
according to at least Hirsch was who
seems to have a closer look at the case
what do you make of the way the left has
turned on Dershowitz like there is such
a visceral hatred for him now I'm trying
to get him on the show well I hate you
right I mean like anybody anybody who's
a quote-unquote turncoat is hated the
most yeah and so - what's yeah you know
has said things that are legally true
about Trump and you know I'd do that
Trump is you're better off with your
bluest men she's suggesting that
everyone who's gonna be lassoed by
aliens and dragged to the Marshall of
the Supreme Court where he'll be
executed by laser firing squad
to his credit do you I mean I'm sure
you've seen them but on Twitter when he
gets attacked by a lot of former
colleagues or a form Yat former
academics he challenges them all
publicly to a debate and as far as I
know no one will do it so yeah that's
just the world we live in traitor you
attack everybody and yeah it's right I
would like to seem to mate Larry tribe
because Larry is off the rails
professor Travis oh I like this one then
I find your witty and dry humor
hysterical have you considered touring
with Dave doing a stand-up duo comedy
routine I'm going back in the season
really I think many I did stand-up for
about 12 years in New York and I've just
booked a couple things in January
February in LA and it's all coming back
so I'm I'll be honest I'm very nervous
about getting out of my zone so I think
there's a big difference
between a political commentator who is
funny and a comedian who is political
and I don't think I'm of the talent
level frankly to do a full-on comedy
routine I think that's stepping out of
stepping out of my lane let them not say
that ben shapiro is not humble hey man
the only reason I oppose the death
penalty is that it's irreversible if you
jail an innocent person you it can at
least set them free to live a life later
on but if you posthumously discover you
can't okay so I so I agree with the idea
that the application could be flawed of
the death penalty that's not an argument
in principle against the death penalty
it's an argument in principle against
the against you know any irreversible
system will I get let's put this way if
you had to get there's two arguments
against the death penalty what is the
effective in this argument which is okay
you killed the guy now you found out
he's innocent everyone admits this is a
bad solution right right but then
there's the second question which is you
know the guy's guilty is the death
penalty inappropriate and that's it
that's the second level of
anti-death-penalty that some people are
and some people are not right like the
Pope is anti-death-penalty
for Hitler Yeah right like for me I'd
put two bullets in Hitler and then beat
him beat his head with a with the butt
of the gun like it's it so I have no
problem with the death penalty in
concept but an application I agree to
their problems I don't know that you
want to answer this but I will ask are
either of you active investors and if so
what do you invest in I'm not really and
I'm not either I sort of have an
investment firm that it does it for me I
will say that I'm I have most of my
money the vast majority of my investment
money is in is in stocks and I have
sought a particularly high risk
portfolio because I'm young and I figure
that if things go to hell in a
handbasket I can still have some time to
make it up you can I have a good life
insurance policy I can rent my room or
something I don't worry about it you'll
be all right thanks for all the effort
guys appreciate both of you it's great
that you may not agree about everything
but we can still talk ok I think we
agree on that do we agree on that no you
don't agree on that we don't agree on ok
what are your opinions on clash of
civilizations and Robert Kaplan's theory
of breakdown in his book Balcon coast so
I don't know the Robert Kaplan book of
civilizations is Huntington and I think
that's more true than Fukuyama I mean
that was that was the big debate in the
90s was Fukuyama versus Huntington right
Samuel Huntington basically posited
there were these civilizations that were
eventually gonna come into conflict I
think one of the most Islamic one of the
most Chinese one of them is the Russians
one of them was Western civilization
that teams have been borne out pretty
well that these civilizations may change
their borders but they still continue to
exist and they will fight with one
another and then there was the the
Fukuyama theory at the end of history
which is basically we reached the end of
history that the liberal democracy was
going to take over the globe and
everything would be hunky-dory and giant
failed you know it's funny I read Clash
of Civilizations my mind immediately
goes to clash of titans what the
original is one of the great movies of
all time okay and again on automating
u.s. congressman do you think that
libertarians and conservatives would
entertain automating the US Congress on
a blockchain I sense people just want me
to say sir I think that's I'm getting
that that's what you know what that
means yeah I don't know what that means
exactly you know maybe Eric Weinstein is
tweeting at us and he's probably this is
kind of interesting hey Ben big fan
you've talked a lot about cultural
values and a little bit about the
stereotype of the wealthy Jew is there
one cultural value in Judaism / culture
that you would point to as a cause you
know it's interesting if I read this
question with a different tone it could
sound anti-semitic but it I think he's
actually saying is this is a cause of
innovation right what he's actually
saying is there what's the reason
they're culturally that Jews tend to be
successful and the answer is that Jews
have always had an extraordinarily high
focus on education so the literacy rate
in the Jewish community back into
ancient times is nearly a hundred
percent for men and women
so Jews have always been very into study
which is why we have giant sets of
Talmud that sit on our shelves and so
the focus on education and literacy was
always a big focus for people coming to
the United States for the immigrants
coming to the United States Jewish
immigrants coming here focused really
heavily on get educated make something
of yourself
and if you focus on it and this isn't
just unique to Jews I mean this is true
for Thomas all has a theory and
basically says that people who are
middlemen in any civilization are the
people who are gonna rise to the top
because they're not benefiting from the
home ground of being natives and they're
yet they're doing all the transactional
work and so that means that they have
their own sort of in-group where they
can negotiate with one another so that
it's like Hasidic diamond merchants
for example they don't need contracts
they can cut out the middleman mm-hmm
and so they can keep costs low and they
can do well that way but also because
they don't have that ground they have to
they're they're forced to use the system
as best they can which usually means
playing by the rules of the system in
the most efficient possible way and so
you see that with a lot of a lot of
Korean immigrants for example who will
come to the United States and then
education is all they care about and
just get educated and rise in the system
and cultures that focus on education do
all end of story
there's been a slew of questions asking
me about Genk in general and the debunk
and these revelations just in the last
couple weeks about that's up I really
know you have a lot to say about the
revelations they started speak for
themselves and shank is chanc and yeah
so I would agree with that but on the on
the debate side because a lot of people
obviously watch the political debate
it's hard to debate certain people who
don't play by the standard rules of
debate right right I mean that in and of
itself is sort of so I thought that the
debate one is bad as well as it was
going to meaning that you know shouting
google it over and over is not I think
the great debate tactic but it was it
was interesting I prepared for that
debate very differently because I've
watched the debates that shanked in with
dinesh d'souza Ann Coulter the couple of
years before and both of those debates
tranqs tactic because the crowd was with
him was to basically find a quote that
was ten years old and then use it
against an or use it against an ash and
then yell at them if they defended
themselves or attempted to to answer a
different question and so I prepared for
that like I if the one of the best
career moves chanc ever made was not
going along on me like if he had done
that in debate it would have been a very
very large mistake yeah I'm sure that
you had your I mean I I don't you know
so that so it didn't go that direction
and so we were able to have you know a
relatively I think for Chang you know
decent and normal conversation about
health care yeah and taxes I was the
only thing that annoyed me about is I
wish we had covered a broader gamut
because it turned into like a health
care to be filled with easier like 60
minutes yeah which I hadn't prepared for
but I don't care I can still do it but
it's it but it wasn't something that I
was like who came to listen to a 60
minute health care debate is weird right
I think I said this to you after that
but that moment that debate which
obviously I was I was
watching with particularly keen interest
it wasn't even anything that you both
said up there that I thought was the
biggest takeaway it was the audience the
fact that the audience young people were
so behind the conservative you know I've
gone to political events and I've gone
to go to events with the Young Turks
where it was like you know it's only
these lefties and progressives and young
people that show up but the cultural
shift now where it's like the young
beauty shot by that book we just did the
turning-point thing these kids were
incredible I mean and they're passionate
we were we were really surprised by it
because I mean Young Turks is a sponsor
of the of evaluation and so they did the
QA and the QA was originally supposed to
wait right before the debate the QA was
originally supposed to be in a room for
I think 200 they to move it into a room
of a thousand and then we were supposed
to do the debate in the room of a
thousand they to move it into the
auditorium with three and so when we
moved over there you know I don't want
to get inside tranqs head but I imagine
that his math might have changed on the
stage when he walked out and was
actively booed by two of the three
thousand people right anyway oh this is
not the same crowd that I debated an
ordinary thats got to be the most hope
for everything that you do on this
planet from you I needing to do it your
show and all that that has to be the
most hopeful oh I mean I have a lot of
hope for young people I mean one of the
things that I I love is and now I get
spotted a lot in public places it's
probably been you know a year since I've
been in a public place and so I could
I'm never having lunch with you at a
kosher place again yeah it was you can't
eat right now your photography I'm going
with strictly non kosher meat place
somewhere take you to lunch you could
bring your own exactly although I have
to say that you know it was very weird I
went to my sister was in town and so she
wanted to go to this this club in
downtown LA which I never go to any of
these sorts of things but my sister is
shocker right but they do have this
place called the Chiquita club downtown
who you ever been there it's really cool
it's it's like an old forty style club
they kept it they maintained it and so
they actually have big bands come in and
they do swing music and all this kind of
stuff and huh and it's really neat you
have to dress like your you have to
actually come in dressed like you're
from the 40s or 50s so I've got like the
full black outfit in the white jacket in
the hotel and and like ten people there
wanted pictures and so it's the what I
got a kick out of is the fact that
everybody who wants a picture is
somebody who's engaged with the ideas
that I'm espousing yeah like there are a
lot of entertaining people a lot more
entertaining
than I am but I think that the fact that
they are interested in the ideas is I
hope what's driving the interest level
yeah I just like because you're engaging
with ideas too and when you're in the
business of ideas I hope that I'm a good
proxy for the ideas that I'm espousing
and if I am then then why take a picture
of me I hope is them being enthusiastic
about the system of values that I think
is important well said
all right you got 10 more minutes yeah I
know I feel a 5:30 I think it's fair for
you you do have a family and other yeah
you have other things to do Twitter or
something from super chat Jordan
Peterson has argued that about 10% of
the population isn't intelligent enough
to perform any job do you agree with
this and if so how do we help them I
don't know that I've ever heard him say
that's big I don't know so if for the
purposes this will go with it there may
be a contingent to people who are not
intelligent enough to perform a job I
doubt it's 10% I mean the unemployment
statistics right now at four so I think
that'd be I think that'd be weird but
you know four there are people who
legitimately can't take care of
themselves like people who are mentally
ill or people who are you know mentally
deficient in some way that they
legitimately can't take care of themself
this is why I think community groups are
so necessary I mean we have groups in my
Orthodox community there's a great
charity called Israel and it's it's a
home for people who who suffer from
mental retardation and those people are
well taken care of the people in the
community donate a lot of money to it
and they have down syndrome most of
these people and it's and it's really
it's quite great I mean I think that
more of those kinds of groups would take
a lot of burden off of government and
also prevent the left from using
government as sort of their their
do-gooder routine oh this is good hey
Ben why what are your thoughts on
Hayek's why I'm not a conservative and
the argument that can serve as default
position is to not do anything but any
movement or capitulation means moving
towards progressivism which is always
pulling towards total sino remain
control I think it's a totally fair when
people say a conservative is about
conserving I always think that's not in
the terminologies won't right I mean
because if you what I use classical
liberal is determine terminology that
you like to use I think that's probably
a better term I mean that's it's more
indicative of where you are like I don't
want to conserve a lot of things in
government right now I want to tear a
lot of the things in government out by
the
so that's not really conservative unless
you're saying I'm trying to conserve
founding your ideas about human liberty
right I'm trying to conserve my
liberalism now so I think that when
people you it's sort of how people have
missed used the word that the term
traditional activism they'll say well
it's judicial activism if you change an
old decision so well that's not what we
mean by judicial activism we mean you
reading something into the Constitution
that's not there but if you were to say
it's judicial activism to say overturn
roe v wade because roe v wade is a bad
legal decision no matter what you think
of abortion then then I am NOT a
judicial activist I guess I mean then
I'm then I would be in that case Pro
judicial activism cuz I'm in favor of
getting rid of Roe right but I'm not a
pro judicial activism guy so this kind
of fussy wonky terminology is not my is
not my favorite yeah
how much have thought have either of you
put into the accelerating technological
progress of the world that will without
a doubt eclipsed current issues I think
there's sort of interesting just related
to AI and automation and all that like
how much we think things have changed a
lot in these last let's say three years
in a lot of respects but that we're
about to cross a threshold where
everything is going to be completely
different yeah so I think that obviously
their benefits and drawbacks technology
can take care of I hope of a lot of our
problems materially speaking people have
asked one of the questions I get a lot
now is the universal basic income the
idea of automation is going to become so
great that even intelligent jobs are
gonna be done by machines and at that
point you need to universal basic income
what I've always said is that at the
point where scarcity ceases to exist and
you have the replicator from Star Trek
and basically can make whatever you want
with the machine then sure then you can
have universal basic income no problem
but that but typically speaking every
time there's a new technological shift
it creates a new set of jobs that go
along with that plus the technology that
I've seen so far has has suggested that
the best the the sort of best
decision-making and most skilled
operations are combinations of human
ingenuity and technology so the best
chess players are not pure computers or
pure humans it's a human using a
computer yeah and so you know maybe
that's the direction that things go but
if I could predict technology would
already be created right so it's so I I
can't fully predict where I think
technology is gonna go yeah I've used
this example a couple of times but
there's a McDonald's in the airport in
Seattle that's now using iPads and
yesterday I was at an airport and Burger
King iPads instead of people and it's
like well if you keep telling them that
they have to pay everyone 15 bucks an
hour guess what you need to see a lot
more of these and a lot less actual
human beings what is your position on
daca and you're a legislative solution
okay so daca for those who knows that
aford action for childhood arrivals
program this is Obama's executive
amnesty in which he basically said that
if you're a dreamer meaning that you
were under the age of 16 or between the
ages of 16 and 30 I believe was and he
arrives as a child then you get to stay
barring any sort of criminal record so
my position on daca is that I am NOT in
favor the reason I'm not in favor is I
think that a country gets to decide who
is citizens are and just because you
arrived here and you've been here for a
long time does not change the country's
capacity for deciding whether your net
benefit or net detriment to the society
now with that said I'm pretty
libertarian on immigration generally if
you're here to work and not here on
welfare and you're not destroying the
culture in any way and you're willing to
and you're willing to acclimate to what
I would consider to be traditional
American values you know hard work the
government doesn't take care of you and
all the rest
then join come on it right I mean that's
I'm totally fine with that
my preferred legislative solution to all
of this is instead of evaluating
everybody on the basis of a class saying
oh well you were tween this age and this
age and from this country and therefore
good you're good I think that's a bunch
of crap I don't understand why the
government has the capacity to look at
hundreds of millions of tax returns
every year but it can't take individuals
and say does this person provide
economic benefit and or cultural benefit
to the United States or not and if you
are if you if you're here illegally and
you're providing benefit to us then we
should basically put you in the back of
the line
and give you an application for
citizenship or or if not citizenship at
least for a green card and give you a
work visa in the mean time okay this
whole treating everybody by classes is
ridiculous man I've never understood
this maybe this is because I'm in
California and in California everyone
has worked with illegal immigrants or
known illegal immigrants or hired nearly
a little bit you know it's always that
awkward country have that awkward
conversation oh yeah I mean if you're
here you always have to have the awkward
conversation where if somebody comes in
and they apply for a job and they want
to work and you're like well can I see
your car your social security card and
they're like why don't have ones I'm not
a citizen and I've always thought it was
incredibly weird that the federal
government wants me to enforce
immigration law
for stilled an immigration law yeah I
mean I've hired even just a couple guys
that work around my house and do some
stuff and fix things and done some stuff
even in the studio that to be a hundred
percent frank with you I hope nobody's
watching but I don't know actually if
they're legal or illegal right I pay
them on the books and all that kind of
stuff but these people work incredibly
hard I'm not driving them out of charity
I have never seen people that work
harder I mean I agree with this and
that's why that's why I've always been
bewildered by this position that the and
this is a position that I think Trump
took and Jeff Sessions as well this
position that people who come here to
work we have to restrict those people
too I've never I've never understood
that like if you're here to work and
you're not gonna mooch off the public
dime then why wouldn't I want you here
there plenty of people who were born
here mooching off the public dime and
not working all right I'm gonna ask you
one more all right not on the iPad it's
mine but you know we they were literally
a gajillion here and ya know we'll do
this again so it's alright what would
you say in our remaining minutes is the
best way for the average person that's
watching this to break the spell so when
I did my direct message from this
morning I said the 2018
I said 2016 was the year of fake outrage
2017
was the year of misguided anger and that
2018 is going to be the year of unusual
alliances that's what I really think is
happening and I think we're sort of like
you have these trilogy wait till you see
the prequels but but that's what I see
sort of happening here that this is
gonna yes the identity politics it's not
going away and all the forces the
post-modernism and all that nonsense
it's not going anywhere yeah but I think
some interesting alliances are gonna be
forming this year and look you just sat
down in front of 2,000 or 3,000 people
with with sam Harris that's an unusual
alignment all your differences what
would you say is the best way for the
average person that just wants to live
in society do you know get a decent job
you know live decently eat some food
have some sex whatever it is that they
play some video games whatever you want
to do in your life I hope you just
described by tomorrow brick to break the
spell of being afraid to say what you
think and and and stand up for what you
believe that all this endless the
outrage machine in the cry
you know for all nothing we just did
this for two hours I don't think you
said anything that sounded remotely
racist or but you got accused of being
on that I had already as soon as we
leave I'm gonna start yeah but but what
would you say to the person that wants
to break out of the spell but is just
afraid well I mean I think the first
embolden ting step is basically saying f
you to people who are implying that you
are something they're not which is funny
because you know we started off by
saying identity politics is garbage and
it is garbage but well the something
else that's garbage is when people are
trying to identify you right they're
giving you your identity so you must be
you're a conservative or you are a
person who disagrees with something the
leftist said or you just somebody who
disagrees with the prevailing notion
that means that you are a bad person
once you say f you to that person you
say you don't have any evidence for that
proposition it's actually a pretty
liberating feeling and once you feel
that liberation it's pretty addictive
because you never want to go back to
this place where you feel like you can
be pushed into a corner just because of
your your political viewpoint Andrew
Breitbart who I was very close to was
very fond of saying that you sort of
have to walk toward the fire and when
you walk toward it what you realize very
often is that it's just a mirage there's
really not a lot of fire there in the
end anyway it's a lot of people who are
shouting and yelling and particularly on
social media there's a lot of people
shouting and yelling like people yell
and shout on Twitter all the time and I
found it amazing but I've been in
someone I've been at the center of some
of the biggest controversies in American
politics over the last two years and
what I found is that on Sabbath when I
turn off my phone from Friday night to
Saturday night none of it is there it's
just not there and I'm interacting with
human beings on a one-to-one level
whether it's my family or members of my
community and that's true for most
people in life so don't get caught up in
the virtual stupidity of people calling
you names and feel free to say you're
being a jerk but most people are not
willing to be as rude to you in person
as they are online and so if we can all
start interacting I think not just as
individuals but also face to face more
you know spending more time with each
other going to events you know maybe we
should we should try to do a joint event
and go out and meet a lot of people you
know I think that that kind of stuff
once people do that they realize that in
the end if we treat each other as
individuals and if that's the goal is a
government that will treat us as
individuals we'll probably end up in at
least the same direction we may not end
up in exactly the same place but our
x-wings will be pointed it toward toward
the right target and you finish with a
Star Wars reference how much more can I
ask
it's always a pleasure talking to you
you know I think thank you for having
we've been on an interesting journey
that sort of parallel each other in just
the the way the media operates and the
way and that the people that hate us and
love us and and the whole thing and this
was the right way to kick-off 2018 well
my dear I now release you to to your
family and to your children right now
just disappear and the two sons in the
distance all that good stuff all right
guys you know where to find Ben Shapiro
it's on Twitter app in Shapiro daily
wire comm what do you want to send them
anywhere else I mean my podcast is on
iTunes or SoundCloud or anything he's
gonna deny cast on iTunes there you go
all right thanks for watching everybody